Do do five,
four,
three,
two,
one young.
Jamie gave me the fake gun.
Pointy fingers.
So alive.
Chris,
Ryan,
Hawaii,
brother.
I'm live.
It's good to be live.
Joe,
you haven't gotten any of this
interdimensional child molester.
We'd yet.
I've been probed.
I don't know who was doing it,
but somebody was probing me.
Interdimensionally.
I'll tell you that.
Just about to talk about getting Alex
Jones high on the podcast before we
start.
And I said save it.
You got to say,
well see,
I'm not that tuned into who he is.
I,
I just hear you know,
occasionally Alex Jones is this right
wing conspiracy guy and I never listened
to him.
So I saw you was on your show and I was
working at home doing some shit around
the house so I put it on youtube so I
could actually see him doing this.
Taking these things off the headphones
on and off.
Oh my God man.
And like for the first hour,
hour and a half,
I was like,
fuck this guy,
about half of what he says actually kind
of makes sense to me and he's obviously
really smart.
High Iq off the fucking charts,
no doubt,
but then he would just veer off and the
more we add in whiskey got involved,
the more it was just like,
this is performance art.
This is just nuts.
Beyond that,
once he started,
right,
right before the podcast,
man,
I want to get a drink and he,
he,
he had some whiskey.
Did he have some whiskey before I got
here?
I've been right as you got it right as I
go.
So I was already here and he's like,
well before we get started,
let me give it,
let me get a drink real quick.
And he went back and I had a drink with
them.
I'm like,
listen,
I'm not going to let them drink alone.
We're going to do this.
Right.
But it was a dangerous proposition
because Eddie Bravo was here and Eddie
Bravo is Mexican and Joey Diaz says that
Mexicans are basically a native
Americans,
which he's right.
You know,
like there's,
there's Mexicans that were native
Americans that bread with the Spanish.
You would know more about this having
lived in Spain and so that's why.
Yeah,
I mean so.
And when grid with Mexicans and
Spaniard,
I don't breed with anyone.
Not really,
but attempted breeding.
I've gone through the motions.
Yeah.
But you know,
they look like some of them look like
people from Spain and some of them look
like native Americans.
It's kind of interesting,
like Mexico is a kind of really diverse
sort of a genetic line.
Um,
but so,
you know,
the old stereotype about native
Americans that you can get them drunk
and the Indian goes fucking crazy.
Well,
Eddie Bravo,
who's Mexican.
Joey Diaz is always saying you get them
drunk.
That fucking Indian comes out.
And that is exactly what happened.
Yeah.
So we got Eddie drunk and he just went
off the fucking rails with.
He thinks the government sprain shit in
the sky and he's been saying it forever,
so,
so much so that he's constantly got legs
confirmation bias thing where he's
constantly looking to confirm.
So he just had this agenda that he had
to talk to Alex Jones even after you
talked about interdimensional child
molesters,
right in Obama's mother sea sex work.
Still crazy.
Oh,
he's awesome.
I think people got a chance to see what
I see in him because like,
everybody's like,
how can you be friends with Alex Jones?
I'm telling you,
he's a great guy.
He's a great guy,
he's a lot of fun and he's right about a
lot of shit.
Well,
the thing,
alright,
somebody emailed me this morning and
they're like,
uh,
you know,
because I had said,
I tweeted like,
Hey,
this guy is actually making sense.
And they were like,
dude,
he's like a.
He denies the Sandy Hook massacre.
Is that true?
I don't know.
That's such,
that's it.
I mean,
that's the kind of thing that for me,
it's like if he's denying that,
then fuck that guy.
He's saying,
you know,
Obama's mother was a CIA sex worker.
That's just funny.
But the,
I mean,
I don't know.
You know what?
I think this is my,
my take on him and I,
like I said,
I love this guy dearly.
Um,
I feel like he's a high high power
corvette engine.
Yeah.
But some of the spark plugs are not
totally connected.
Yeah.
So like the Obama's wife is a CIA,
Mama's Mama was a cia sex slave and
sandy hook and we've got the documents.
There's a few of those things that get
through where maybe if he had someone
next to them going,
let's look at this objective.
He,
isn't it possible that this could be the
case or isn't it possible that that
could be the case and it's the opposite
of what he's got is millions of people
saying,
yeah,
give us more of that.
People fucking love conspiracy theories.
They loved them,
they loved them and you know,
see,
this is where I was.
I was surprised to be agreeing with them
because.
Because we do live in a conspiracy,
it is a conspiracy.
Modern civilization is a fucking lie.
So I agree that,
you know,
where he saying like,
we're being.
He was talking about sort of,
I think he gets into lizard people and
that kind of thing.
He does.
No,
he doesn't get into lizard people.
All right,
well I'm David Eick.
Oh,
okay.
I,
I get into a super organisms,
like I think we're embedded in a super
organism.
You and I've talked about this before,
I think,
and that's why we as a species are doing
things that are detrimental to our own
interests as individual human beings
because we are embedded in the super
organism just like our bacteria is
embedded in us and you know,
using the super organism,
the earth itself,
like what do you think?
It's technology too.
And so,
uh,
I mean you and I and Duncan and talked
about this a bunch and we were doing the
shrimp parade thing because I see,
I see it as the end of humanity and that
is a negative thing because I kind of
like,
I like the way we lived for 200,000
years embedded in the environment like
other animals and pretty fucking happy
and living in the moment and all that,
you know,
uh,
where it's,
Duncan thinks it's great that we're
spreading out into the universe and you
know,
even if we stopped being humans to do
that,
which is,
it's a,
it's a fascinating conversation.
So anyway,
I'm crazy too,
is my point,
right?
So I think there's a certain amount of
craziness that certainly called for.
I don't think you're crazy.
I think you're looking at like you're
extrapolating,
you're just looking at what's going on
and they didn't mean it's really clear
what you're saying is absolutely
correct.
We're not operating in the best interest
of the species.
Right.
If we continue,
do you just see this new crack in the
fucking Holy Shit.
It's grown over the last couple of
months by like a mile and the things
like the size of Delaware or something
enormous.
And if it breaks off Foxville just a
gigantic floating iceberg like the size
of a state might just head to Hawaii and
fucking crash into it.
Like this shocking animation reveals how
massive hell a massive Antarctic crack
has grown 17 miles in the last two
months.
Hold on,
let's go back.
Let's go back.
Uh,
and experts say it's now inevitable that
it will create one of the biggest
icebergs ever seen.
Holy Shit.
Inevitable size of Jamaica.
Oh my God.
Look at it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It would be so scary to see like a
floating state in the ocean and
Fukushima radiation is worse than ever,
ever,
and they don't know what to do.
They have no idea how to contain it.
Not all problems are solvable.
No.
Yeah.
Well that Fukushima.
It scares the shit out of me because
they don't really know how to shut off a
lot of those ancient power plants.
The ones that they first correct
created.
Essentially they just have to keep
running,
like grow the fuck.
Let whoever the fuck let them do that is
so crazy.
They don't know how to shut them off.
We'll see so much.
A technology is based on this idea that,
you know,
when we need,
when we face the problem,
we'll have an answer to it.
You know,
like the disposal of nuclear waste.
Right.
Well we'll figure that out.
We'll shoot it into space or will.
We know they have.
They've kind of figured out a way to
turn nuclear waste into batteries.
They turned it into diamonds that lasts
for like they embedded into diamonds and
it can last.
What was it?
The,
the,
the technology of the battery can last
thousands of years.
Really.
Oh,
it's amazing.
And let's get on that.
Well,
there was a.
Who was,
which podcast was it that we were doing
where someone was talking about a young
scientist.
Do you remember who was who?
They were talking about a young
scientist that has these incredible
ideas.
Oh yeah,
I was there.
I met him.
That was the one I did in 2012 or 11.
He,
he does this little reactor in the
backyard,
essentially meant to many podcasts,
but it was,
it was fairly recently.
Just go over the fairly recent podcasts
and vice did a thing on him.
It was Shane Smith.
There you go.
Perfect.
Is Shane Smith from vice?
Yeah.
Um,
so maybe he's right or maybe people are
right that we will come up with
technology that's going to be able to
figure out a way to solve these
problems.
Well,
but it doesn't see that's the thing here
we are Fukushima,
we don't have the technology.
We don't know how to solve it when we
need it,
you know,
or a year ago or you know,
and dump.
We bear this radio,
diamond batteries making good use of
nuclear waste,
so they're going to have these diamond
battery that lasts for thousands of
years,
which is really incredible because what
Shane Smith was saying is essentially we
have enough nuclear waste to power the
earth for thousands of years.
Our civilization like we can literally
stop.
We can stop all production of batteries
and all the different things that we're
doing coal.
Here's where we're getting into
conspiracy shit again.
They won't let us do it.
They'll shut that shit down because it
will lose jobs.
Like right now they're trying to open
coal mines again for fucks sake.
You know,
who's they?
Coal miners.
Coal Mine,
uh,
unions and coal mine presidents.
And the guy,
you know,
Exxon,
that guy from Exxon who's going to be
secretary of state,
tillerson.
Wonderful.
That's the guy who said,
what's the point of saving the earth if
humans have to suffer?
Is that what he said?
Yeah.
Smart Guy.
Ridiculous person.
Anyway.
Well,
I don't want to drag us down and
depressing.
Not Depressing.
Yeah,
I think we were right though that what
you're saying about technology and about
we're serving technology.
I mean,
I've been saying this for a long time
that I essentially think that what we're
doing is giving birth.
We're,
we're a larva form.
Were like some sort of a butterfly
that's gonna emerge or we will be a
butterfly and a caterpillar.
Right now we're creating the iphones and
I'm a caterpillar going.
God Damn it.
I liked the color stage,
but you don't want to lose it.
Don't you think those single celled
organisms like guys,
what are we doing?
We're branching out.
We're fucking joining together with
other cells.
Fuck that man.
I liked being by myself being
essentially immortal,
immortal,
single celled squid.
It could be,
but when you're,
you're,
uh,
advancing stage requires the destruction
of your entire environment and all the
other species as well.
That's kind of fucked.
It is fucked.
But I don't know if it's all the
species.
I think rats will be fine if he watched
that netflix documentary on rats.
Yeah.
No,
I saw you posted some shit and I was
like,
Nina and I want to see that.
It is amazing.
It has no rats will be fine.
Keith Richards,
there'll be fine cockroaches.
I need 25 percent of the species have
gone extinct in the last generation.
Something like that.
Well,
that always happens though.
See,
this is not at this rate.
No,
I mean this is a mass extinction event,
but there's always been mass extinction
events.
There's been a ton of them and there's
90 percent of everything that's ever
lived as dead everything,
every living organism.
But that's obscuring the reality,
right?
The rate of extinction right now due to
human interventions is higher than it's
been in probably hundreds of millions of
years.
Young Jamie can look at a case.
So the last major extinction event was,
you know,
hundreds of millions of years ago,
I think it was 65 million years ago.
The thing is that dinosaurs,
I think it was the what,
what killed off the dinosaurs and there
was also a major extinction event in
North America that coincided with the
end of the Ice Age,
about 10 fold.
Right?
Which they attributed to humans.
No,
no,
they don't anymore.
Yeah.
Well some people do,
but what they're thinking now due to a
lot of geological data is asteroidal
impacts.
Oh,
we were at Randall Carson.
Is he on that?
Yeah,
I never bought that human thing.
I think this whole man,
the hunter bullshit.
Cause like they didn't even have bows
and arrows.
They have adult models,
which are cool.
They're cool.
They're pretty cool invention.
Good luck.
That's the fucking saber tooth tiger
with that.
The last one too.
They're like five left and you're going
to hunt them down and kill them.
I don't think so.
It just wasn't enough people here to do
that and it's much more likely
considering the fact they found these
essentially like graveyards filled with
wooly mammoths had died instantaneously.
The asteroid impact theory also a lot
of,
um,
you know,
the big game died,
the,
the giant,
the carnivores.
The big giraffes and all that shit that
was here,
but also a lot of shellfish went extinct
at the same time and snails and things
like that.
Here we go.
Extinctions during human error.
Worse than thought the gravity of the
world's current extinction rate becomes.
It becomes clear upon knowing what it
was before people came along.
A new estimate finds of species die off
as much as 1000 times more frequently
nowadays than they used to.
It's 10 times worse than the old
estimate of 100 times who,
oh,
that's not good,
and that's three years ago.
This is a three year old article in that
funny,
like three years ago,
people like shit's old bro.
Shit's from September Bro.
Isn't it funny?
We're.
We're moving at such a fast rate that
our minds are kind of tuned into that
and when anybody.
Someone shows you something,
it's from a year ago.
You're like,
Bro,
you're quoting a year old stuff.
Tell me about.
I'm trying to write a book,
like talk about an ancient technology.
It's like I'm trying not to refer to
papers that were published 10 years ago,
but you know,
how can you not,
I mean there's crazy 10 years ago is
nothing.
Yeah.
I mean,
Darwin was a long fucking time ago.
What we're looking at is this weird
accelerated existence and it's,
it's happening right in front of it and
we sort of acknowledged it,
but we're not recognizing it.
We've acknowledged it.
What we can't comprehend it now,
like we're living in a world we can't
comprehend,
which again gets back to this whole
hunter gatherer thing.
Like you lived in a world they
understood,
you know,
this whole,
like we assume the generational,
uh,
misunderstanding or sort of common human
behavior,
human experience.
But if you're a hunter gatherer,
your parents and grandparents lived in
the same world you live in and they do
now.
I mean,
you saw that recently,
uncontacted tribe like recently
contacted tribe in Brazil.
I mean,
it's incredible.
They're there,
they're live there.
They're a,
they're a time capsule.
They're living the way people lived
100,000
years ago.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's really cool.
It's really.
The pictures are amazing.
Cds,
people pointing,
bows and arrows,
and helicopters.
What have you ever heard?
There's a great book called at play in
the fields of the Lord by Peter
Matheson's.
I've heard of it.
I've never read it.
It's a beautiful bug man.
It's a really good film to Daryl Hannah,
John Lithgow,
Kathy Bates,
amazing cast.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's about,
it's a novel,
but it's about this,
uh,
these two guys.
Oh,
Tom Waits is one of the actors in the
play pilots.
They're like smugglers,
whatever.
And they get hired to go in and bomb
this uncontacted tribe before the
missionaries make contact with them
because once they are contacted then all
their land gets set aside as a reserve
and this corrupt politician wants to log
in and mine and you know,
all the shit.
So he hires these two ne'er do wells to
go in and bomb them.
Well,
and uh,
I mean,
I'm not ruining the story.
This is like the first 20 pages.
You get the setup and what happens is
they,
uh,
they go out and they sort of fly over
the first day and they see,
they see the clearing in the jungle and
all the Indians run into the jungle and
then they're sort of flying low.
There may be a thousand feet up and this
one warrior runs into the clearing and
fires an Arrow at the airplane and
they're laughing like this fucking guy
thinks he's going to shoot down an
airplane with an Arrow,
you know,
and they go back to the village and one
of the pilots,
it's Tom Waits and I'm forget the other
actor,
but he plays a Navajo and they're like
Vietnam vets bombing around South
America with their plane,
right?
And they're back in the village and I
get shit faced.
And then the Tom waits character goes to
bed and the other guy's still hanging
out in this little bar and somebody
slips him.
Some IOWASCA.
And so he's already drunk.
He drinks this Iowasca heats,
like,
starts hallucinating.
He goes out,
gets in the airplane,
flies off in the air in the middle of
the night,
flies out to this spot in the jungle
where they saw where they're supposed to
bomb them that day.
Instead he puts on a parachute,
ditches the plane,
jumps out.
Oh my lands in the jungle,
takes off all his clothes and his
pistol,
buries it in the jungle and then walks
naked into the village to spoiler alert.
No,
no.
That's the beginning of the movie
beginning.
Hold on a second.
I'm writing this down as young as he
sexy bitch.
Look at them.
Yeah.
And what was this?
The film 90.
Wow.
I was fresh out of John Lithgow.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
that's,
that's how it begins.
Peter Matheson's a great writer.
He uh,
he was a hard hardcore dude.
Real bad ass guy.
But anyway,
um,
that's how it starts.
So,
so this guy literally goes back in time,
right?
Because he's a Navajo and when he saw
that guy shoot the Arrow,
he sort of had this vision of how his
people had lost their dignity and their
culture had been destroyed.
And if only they had known what they
were facing and these people in the
jungle,
I have no idea what's coming for them.
Right.
And so his mission is I'm going to go
back and save them because I can tell
them what's coming.
I can,
you know,
move through worlds.
I can move back in time and it's fucking
wild.
What a great plot.
Jesus Christ high right now.
Scaring
the shit out of me.
So La Man,
I'm back in La.
What happened?
I thought you were going to be an ex.
Pat.
You're going to fucking get out of here
before the big one landed a.
yeah,
I'm still,
I'm watching.
I'm watching very closely at all before
they close the door.
I'm gonna I gotta weigh out.
What's it like coming back right at the
time when Donald Trump becomes
president?
It's an adventure,
Huh?
It's strange.
The.
I feel like I was saying this on my
podcast the other day.
I feel like the like,
you know how the solar system is moving,
you know the whole galaxy is moving.
So there are all these zones.
I gotta be careful,
man.
I'm talking about don't be countered.
Don't be careful.
There's no need to be careful.
Think about Tom Waits.
Is it Tom Waits?
Is that the name of the actor?
No,
that's the center.
Tom Waits and Tom Barrett.
He's the same guy.
The same guy.
Okay.
And then Tom Berenger who was in saving
private Ryan,
right.
Or platoon platoon.
He was the bad guy and platoon with a
scar on his face and I think so,
yeah,
it was great.
Speaking of mediators,
did you guys see this in Michigan at the
other day?
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
A giant fucking hunk of metal from the
sky slammed into a or something from
this guy slammed into Lake Michigan.
Look at that.
That might've actually burned out before
it hit the ground.
So you see it like kind of fizzle and
towards the end it's amazing what the
atmosphere does.
Just things coming through the
atmosphere.
Like remember when the space shuttle
lost some tiles and then burned out in
the atmosphere.
I'm good Jim.
It's just amazing that our air just
traveling through the air at a high rate
of speed destroys things.
It just rips them apart,
you know,
burns him up.
Yeah.
Well,
the,
the threat of the impact for something
that's in space is ever looming and
always ignored mean we rarely think
about it until something like this
happens and I think it's just so scary
that there's part of our brain that just
puts it off.
We just go.
Yeah,
and then move on to the next thing.
Nothing you could do about it.
It's definitely going to happen.
It's happened before you look up at the
moon.
There's an amazing video that Neil
degrasse Tyson posted on his instagram
page the other day and it's a guy using
a camera and he has some incredible lens
on it.
Oh yeah,
I saw that.
And you,
you,
you mean he's got a really good camera
and you get really cool by the way,
that might not be nailed to God.
The grass Tyson's actual page.
I think it might be like a fan page
because it links up to twitter and the
twitter is Neil degrasse Tyson fan,
so it might not be his real instagram
page.
Well,
whatever.
It's an awesome video and it gets to a
really close up when it gets really
close up.
The thing you see is just craters
everywhere.
Well,
there's no atmosphere to protect them.
Exactly.
But then what?
Drop the charges dropped
and then you start thinking about how
much shit is out there.
Like that thing is just covered.
It's just covered with but time.
Think about how long it's been out there
to.
You know,
I'm the one I'm worried about is the
solar flare.
Oh yeah.
You know because that was it like 1880
or something.
There was a big one in North America and
it melted out the transmission cables
for the claymores cohorts code guys the
Telegraph.
So when that hits,
like all our computers are gone now,
computers are our grid.
Yeah.
The transformers are out.
So they're saying if something like that
does happen and you can never predict if
or when it would take months to get
power back up.
Yeah.
And people live in Phoenix in August,
they're fucked.
Yeah.
I mean [inaudible] you live in a cold
place,
at least you could burn wood.
I mean,
people did that for a long time.
They figured out fire.
There was actually an article recently
about neanderthals and they're trying to
figure out when there's still a debate
as to whether or not they actually knew
how to make fire or whether they knew
how to keep it lit or once they found it
right,
you know that they would find it.
It would be like the sacred fire and
they would keep it lit,
but they weren't quite smart enough to
actually make it,
but now they're thinking that might not
be the case.
They might have had a lot of debate on
that.
Yeah.
You studied a lot of ancient
civilizations.
How much,
how much debate is there?
Like whenever I hear someone say people
definitely did this.
They definitely did that.
You know,
like when they're looking back at
evidence like as far as far as like who
could handle fire?
Like who was the first people in,
when did they figure it out,
how do they put all that shit together?
Well,
I mean it depends on the specific case.
Right.
With in the case of fire with they're
looking at is uh,
and,
and also because it's so,
there's such a scarcity of evidence.
Things change really quickly,
right?
Like for a long time,
they thought people crossed over,
the first few North Americans are about
10,000
years ago and now they're saying,
oh,
at least 14.
And now they're finding places in Chile
what appear to be 40,000
and other union,
they came over in boats and there were
several different,
you know,
groups that came in different ways.
So there's a lot of change in that
because there's so little evidence that
when a new piece comes in,
it really radically transformed things.
But with fire,
what they're looking at is,
um,
evidence of fire concurrent with human
habitation.
So with carbon dating,
you can figure out the age of the coals
or the stuff that's left in the ash.
Um,
and then you'd look at pieces of bone or
something that they were cooking.
And if you get the same area then you
can figure,
okay,
they were,
this wasn't a fire 10,000
years after somebody ate a rat here or
something.
Right there cooking yet,
especially if the bones show charring as
well,
then they're cooking the food,
but that's just in the last 15 or 20
years.
The estimate of human use of fire has
gone from like
500,000
years to a million.
Isn't that crazy?
They just keep back dating things.
Yeah,
so fascinating.
Just to those mounds they found in the
Amazon really recently they used drones
and they were getting these photographs,
drones or satellites or getting these
images from space from,
from above rather show like grids and
they show all these.
These structures that they previously
had never recognized.
Didn't notice.
Some of them look like stonehenge in the
same sort of shape.
Apparently.
There's like irrigation canals and
stuff.
Yeah.
They have no idea who,
uh,
what's this?
Yeah.
I have this idea it.
I have a lot of.
I need like a bunch of graduate students
because I have ideas for books,
but I never get around to writing the
story of my life should be like,
I need a stat.
You should be like a guy who tells it
like,
people,
we need to work on this.
If you're curious but you're not
disciplined or you don't have the time,
honestly,
ideas,
but in between doing your podcast,
writing your book and live in your life,
how much time do you have left?
Live in my life.
Takes up a lot of time.
You,
I appreciate that about you.
I really do.
I appreciate that.
You,
uh,
you have a very um,
very.
It's an intelligent but it's an honest
way of looking at time.
You know,
you don't have like this overwhelming
ambition and you don't have like this
overwhelming desire to be recognized or
anything like that,
but you do have an overwhelming desire
to have fun and be comfortable and be
curious.
So you're saying I'm a lazy fucking
hippies.
Were you?
You're having a good time.
I think you might be doing it right.
I get all the people that I know that
are super smart.
You like the least stress.
Super Smart Dude.
I know.
Oh,
thank you.
I appreciate that.
I quote you on that,
on my next book,
but man,
I mean considering you're always around,
you always enjoy in different parts of
the world.
You're always coming back with these
crazy stories and interesting
perspectives are you gathered up,
but you don't seem stressed and so many
people that I know that are like in your
intellectual realm are fucking freaking
out all the time.
To me.
I mean,
if I'm stressed,
it's.
I get stressed by my lack of stress.
That's my biggest problem.
I think you're built for podcasts.
I really do.
I think your,
your mind and your curiosity,
it's like you're,
you're trapped in this medium.
I mean,
it's not that I don't think your book is
Great.
I thought sex at dawn was amazing.
Why do I keep coughing?
Is that the weed?
Sex at dawn was amazing,
but uh,
you,
you're really well suited for podcasts.
You're really well suited for freeform
conversations.
You can tell you enjoy it,
you know?
And again,
it's not very stressful.
No,
that's what I love about it.
I did one last night.
I,
I occasionally do a,
what I call a Roma renting out my ass
episode
and it's where it's just me.
No gas.
Right?
So last night I did,
when I'm drinking beer,
I'm like reading letters from people and
yeah,
and going off on whatever the fuck I'm
going off on and it occurred to me later
like that,
you know,
I'm not dealing with the kind of numbers
you're dealing with,
but you know,
I've got a stadium of people listening
to me fucking stadium,
but I am more relaxed than if I were
talking to a friend on the phone because
I don't see anybody.
I'm just alone drinking a beer,
talking into this microphone and I don't
feel the presence of anyone listening.
So I'm totally fucking relaxed sometimes
to my detriment.
I probably say things I shouldn't say
and share shit that I've meant to keep
private or whatever.
But it's,
it is a weird thing.
I mean Jamie and I were talking about
this earlier,
like when you said,
Hey Chris,
you,
it's been awhile to come.
This is like,
yeah,
I'm going to go hang out with my buddy
joe.
Yeah.
But there are a fucking million people
hovering around here listening to us.
You know,
it's really weird,
like 90 percent of my friendship with
you has taken place here.
I know,
right?
It's so.
And it's the same worries,
the same Moshe Kasher.
I've got all these friends who I only
see when we're on a fucking mind,
you know,
it's really interesting is Duncan and I,
we were having a really hard time
spending time together because he's
always busy.
We'd have a really hard time with only a
few times we got together and just hung
out as friends over the last couple of
years,
but we did so many podcasts together for
that and we'd have these conversations.
Like one of the things that's unique
about this form is that you have these
conversations that are like so isolated
from any distraction and I don't think
that exists anywhere else anymore.
Good point.
Just to people looking at you.
That's why I don't like when people look
at their phones.
I don't like when people like bring a
laptop or something like that.
It's like,
man,
I try to close mine now.
I used to not.
I used to look at it.
It's not smart.
The smart thing to do is just put it
down and this form of conversation that
collect the kind of like I would
encourage people to have podcasts,
have their own podcast,
not even if they want to read,
they don't.
You don't even have to release it,
but by doing it,
but just the act of doing it,
you're,
you're having these conversations,
these extended conversations with people
and I think it,
it exercises your thought process in a
way and the engagement process.
It focuses your mind.
People used to say,
some famous writer said,
I write to see what I think,
you know.
I think podcasting sort of the same.
The way you're describing it,
it's true.
It's,
it's one place where we turn off all the
distractions and just focus.
I,
my plan now is to get a van.
I want to get a sprinter van and like
put a bed in it and a little kitchen
with the country,
travel the country doing podcasts.
Ooh,
that's a great idea.
And I had this other idea because
because I see you've got enough weight
that people will come to you,
but I don't want to do shit on skype and
phone and I hate.
I hate that.
Yeah.
It feels weird,
right?
Yeah.
There's delays
and you're talking over each other and
you can't see the body language.
You don't know if they're disengaging
from what you're talking about or
they're getting uncomfortable.
Maybe you're getting too personal,
you know,
I really like being in a room with
somebody.
Also,
the kind of people that I have on my
podcast are like,
you,
they're people you want to know.
They're interesting.
Fucking people,
you know.
So I want to like hang out and meet
their friends and meet the husband or
the wife and the kids and sit in the
driveway in my van for a few days and
get to know the crowd.
And I was thinking I'd love to meet.
Um,
what's his name?
Dan In bisbee.
Your buddy.
Uh,
that Santa Get up.
I'd love to.
And Bimbo.
Bimbo.
Bingo.
Yeah,
you can love them.
My Buddy,
uh,
Jake Johansen.
Do Comedians Love Jake?
Jake's green guy,
so I was at his house and he,
we were talking about how comics think
differently because I was like,
I love hanging out with you guys because
nobody gets offended about anything.
You can just say whatever the fuck comes
out of your head out of your mind.
Right.
And he was like,
we were talking about podcasts and I
said something about Stan Hope,
and he's like,
dude,
you gotta listen to the cliffhanger
episodes.
Have you heard those?
Know?
What did he do?
Oh my God,
there it was like three years ago,
I went back into the archives and
archives and found them.
He had this thing where he has this
couple living in the house in the
backyard and like they'd met by chance
and then it turned out that he had
fucked the woman 15 years earlier after
a gig in Reno or something.
And so now she's with her boyfriend and
they're living in the backyard and
they're all buddies and the four of them
are all the two couples I guess had a
sexual thing and it was all cool and it
was just really beautiful.
And they're talking about how they met
in the history of the relationship and
all that.
The boyfriends there,
the girlfriend's not there.
It turns out the girlfriends in the
hospital about to have open heart
surgery.
That was the cliffhanger.
Holy Shit.
So at the end of this hour and a half,
two hour conversation where they're
talking about this,
you know,
this relationship with it turns out like
she's going to have open heart surgery.
She might be dead.
Folks tune in next week to find out if
she's dead and they're laughing,
but they're laughing and this was jake's
point.
They're processing grief through
laughter and that there is nothing new.
And they're not denying how intense and
sad and scared they are.
But they're still laughing,
isn't it?
Finally grief over death is one of the
few things where we demand you behave a
certain way.
Well,
they're Irish wakes right where
everybody gets drunk and laughs.
Yeah.
But Intel's crazy body stories about the
dead guy.
That's how you celebrate the life.
Hm.
That's a good way.
Yeah.
I think it's a very.
This imposed sadness,
this sort of seriousness.
I think he's very sort of Protestant.
Yeah,
there's,
there's
a little bit of that,
but there's also,
I think we want to know who feels bad,
you know,
because if you don't feel bad like
tribally,
I think that's a very dangerous person
to have around.
Like say if you die,
it's like a psychopath or something.
Yeah.
I really think that might be something
to that.
Like we might enforce it and there might
be like this urge and instinct to
enforce extreme grief because we feel
like people who,
who don't feel that are either not on my
team really didn't care about the person
that I cared about or might be a psycho.
Right.
Interestingly,
some cultures have professional mourners
like greet you,
how chip Pan,
you know,
you pay him to come to the funeral and
they'll,
we'll and scream and cry and express the
emotion so the other people can just
sort of chill and wow,
you know,
go to the buffet.
Did you see after Kim Jong,
Il,
Kim Jong Il died in North Korea,
that people were being punished because
they didn't mourn hard enough.
They got six month jail sentences
because they didn't mourn hard enough
and they were just the worst fake acting
like all throughout the streets and
they're filming it for their propaganda
films,
but it's like,
see if he could pull some of it up.
It's kind of hilarious.
It's hilarious and terrifying.
North Korea terrifies me and one of the
things that terrifies me the most about
it is that it is in our face everyday
direct evidence that things could go
terribly wrong at any point in time with
human beings and we got so fucking lucky
that we're born who at wherever you are
that you can listen to this and not have
to worry about being locked up for
possessing it,
whether it's in England or Norway or
Canada or wherever you're listening to
this.
We got sold lucky.
You could've easily been bored in North
Korea.
Any of us can be born in a prison in
North Korea where you're born as a
prisoner and you'll die as a prisoner
and that's going on right now.
In 2017,
there is a fucking military dictatorship
and they're killing people and
imprisoning people.
And the lights are off at night when you
fly over it and they take satellite
footage of it.
You see the lights are all off like
these people wailing on the street.
Immediate is fucking Uber Bizarre there.
They're all on their knees.
Whaling,
but not a god damn tier to be seen.
They're just throwing their.
I mean,
they're probably scared to that they're
going to be beaten if they don't.
Well hard enough.
So they're scared of that.
Oh,
that'll make you curse is the emotion.
But this is,
this is unbelievable that human beings
no different than us.
There's no difference between them and
us.
They're just there.
Yeah.
That guy could be your neighbor.
Like one of those people wailing could
be,
you know,
Francis,
your neighbor,
and you could be this awesome guy.
Like,
dude,
what's up man?
How are you?
Oh,
everything's good.
You know,
blah,
blah.
Same Guy.
Could be the same guy,
just got born and a better,
better spot.
These are all women.
Oddly enough,
this is all women whaling.
Oh,
there's some men that they have to
separate
so they don't fuck with it.
You don't want any fucking monkey
business while you screaming,
look at these guys crying,
looking at,
uh,
it's so strange,
so strange,
but this is happening today,
so I understand this a different part of
the world,
but you got to,
we have to all recognize that it's just
dumb luck that we were born here because
there's these systems that exist
whenever you have gigantic groups of
people that are at least fairly isolated
and these systems,
these operating systems,
they,
they get enforced and it doesn't matter
where they are.
Once they get enforced,
they're super difficult to break like
those surrey women who cut their lip and
stick those plates in them and stretch
their lips out and do like,
that's a part of a system that exists in
that area.
And that system is the women are trying
to get away from it now.
And a lot of women are like,
I don't want to slobber all the time.
I don't want to knock my teeth out to
put some fucking stupid plate in this.
I heard of a tribe where women,
um,
laser the hair off their pussies.
Oh,
I heard about that when sometimes they
wax it right and the usage of shade it
and they were the shoes with like a big
stick in the back so they can't walk.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
The things people will do in the women
wear these like really short skirts.
I described like Megan Kelly's outfit
and my bit was a bit I'm working on
right now that I talk about what she's
wearing.
It's basically a vagina curtain.
I saw your bit the other night.
That literally is what it is.
It's just these beautiful women on TV,
on the news,
and they were wearing something that
just.
There's,
you know of could lift that up and fuck
her with it.
That's part of the.
That's part of the skirt is lift.
That's the whole point of it.
That's why that fatal attraction scene
with Susan,
what was in it and that Susan Sharon,
Sharon stone,
it was so impactful because we've all
imagined that a million times,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Know she did.
Look at that.
Kick the fuck out of dodge.
If she didn't have that clipboard,
they're blocking the light.
The glorious light.
Look at this.
This is crazy,
man.
That's crazy.
That's a crazy outfit.
That is a sexy outfit and I like her.
I think she's very smart.
Very interesting woman and I'm,
I'm curious to see what happens to her
now that she's at NBC.
Maybe she'll come on the Joe Rogan
experience.
I don't want it to be cross from around
stammer stammer a pan.
You can do it from a remote location.
We have to do that one by skype.
I don't be calling me and I guess I
could handle it.
I can do it.
I have a thing for ice princesses as
long as I said Hi.
Do you like the Ice Princess?
Something about me that uh,
I think that I like are very powerful,
articulate woman like that.
It's very,
very exciting.
We'll see.
[inaudible].
That's it.
You're the opposite of me.
You were saying I'm like the stress
free.
You kinda got your,
all about the challenge.
Only something I'm not like,
I'm not trying to fuck her or anything
like that.
I like,
not that,
that kind of challenge,
but I am fascinated that you came here
from working out.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
and then like you,
because it's funny you talked about my
life being like this sort of carefree
easy going thing.
I think of you,
you're like,
you're like the Martha Stewart of men or
something.
Like you do everything.
How do you do you're living like I
dropped your name occasionally and
someone will be like,
oh,
the podcast guy.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
And like his friend will go away.
I thought he was the UFC guy.
Yeah.
That too.
Like,
but wait isn't either,
like you have nine lives and you're
living them all.
How the fuck do you do that?
I don't know.
Your efficiency.
You never sleep.
Plus you're a father,
you're a husband.
I do all that stuff.
I just,
I think it's,
it's an illusion that it takes more time
than it does with all the stuff that I
do.
I don't have a job.
Job Chill.
Fuck yeah.
Real.
When I watched like documentaries and
shit,
but see that's a chill and that's why I
can't chill,
chill,
chill.
Just like getting your hammock and put
your hands behind your head and go do,
do,
do you ever do that?
My brain doesn't work like that so that
my brain's like my day to do something.
Come on,
shower.
I love showers.
You take long,
like a nice 10 minute hot shower,
pleasure and showers.
Do you have like a good shit in the
shower and that's your chill time?
I went to Alaska to Prince of Wales.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
Prince of Wales Island and uh,
it is this unbelievably wet spot and it
rains there more than I think anywhere
else in North America.
It's incredible.
I mean it's just constantly drenched
with southeast.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is geographically.
I flew in for this TV show mediator with
my friend Steven Rinella and my friend
Brian Cowen and Yonis retell us and we
went to this island.
It was amazing.
It was amazing experience.
So beautiful and so remote and so crazy.
And it wasn't even a successful hunting
trip,
but it was amazing.
The experience was amazing,
but one of the most amazing things about
it was that I was wet and uncomfortable
in this weird sort of environment where
you never really get dry because it's
constantly raining for five or six days
and then when I got home I was so happy.
I was so happy.
I was happy in a way that I'd never been
before in a way,
during a regular day,
just driving down the street to the
studio and coming in and hanging out
with Jamie and doing a podcast and I
just felt so good.
I felt so good.
You felt good to be back or just that?
It wasn't.
I feel good to be back.
It was.
I feel good.
I feel really good and I think that
especially for California,
the weather here is so god damned good
that we have a few days where it rains
and people literally start to complain
and I'm like,
do you know how crazy it is that you're
complaining that it rains maybe 10 days
a year out of 365,
and the [inaudible] latest so beautiful
after they're cleared.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
There's no bugs.
Okay.
I mean this place is so easy to get by
with.
There's very little wildlife that were
ever concerned with.
We just live this ideal.
It can idolic what's the word?
Have delicate.
A delicate sounds wrong though,
doesn't it?
It's not an idol.
It's an ideal.
We live a fairytale life for anywhere.
Anyone else anywhere in the world.
And I think just coming here from the
rain soaked island,
like as I was driving around,
I was,
I would realize like,
oh,
at least for me,
I have to go through some intense
struggle to appreciate normal existence.
There is no Yang without yen.
That's for me for sure.
And there's no comfort without
discomfort.
So for me,
like for me to be happy and calm and
like sit here and talk to you.
I,
I all beat the fucking shit out of a
heavy bag for an hour.
So the,
I wish wail on that thing.
I wish I had that hunger.
I that need.
I've got friends like I can't,
I can't relax if I don't run three miles
a day.
Like fuck,
I wish I had that.
I can read.
I can get out of bed and go right to the
hammock.
I'm fine.
I don't need to do interval.
It's good.
It's good that you could do that and it
isn't.
It isn't.
See that's.
I don't get shit done.
I need more of that because a,
I'd get more shit done,
but then it's like,
why get shit done?
You know,
like what am I trying to get to if I'm
already there?
It's,
that's why I think podcasts are your
shit.
Yeah.
Because effortless.
Just turn it on and do it and maybe like
the way you're doing it with that
ranting.
The Roma one,
that's a great idea.
Bill bird does that and it's incredibly
entertaining.
Bill Burrs,
podcasts,
one of the best podcast you'll ever
listen to and it's always just him.
It was watch when he's on your show.
You guys have a good thing.
I love him.
He's amazing.
And his new comedy.
Netflix special rather is out now.
It's called a walk your way out.
So right now I haven't seen any yet,
but I saw him do all that material,
so I'm sure it's going to be fucking
amazing.
Yeah,
he's great.
he's,
you know,
he's a hard worker to know that guy.
Um,
he works on efforts for family.
He's got his own animated show.
He works on that,
works on Standup,
does this podcast twice a week by
himself.
He just had a kid recently,
just had a kid recently.
Intense family thing going on,
a lot going on.
Great Guy.
Just a great guy.
It is funny.
I mean Jamie and I were talking about
this earlier,
how like La,
I've been here a couple months now so
I'm sort of getting my head back into
it.
Everything's the opposite here.
Like even to the point where people
think like,
oh,
you're living in la.
They're picturing Hollywood where you
live and where I live it's fucking owls
and coyotes.
It doesn't look like.
Especially if you live where you live is
one of the most awesome spots around
love.
It's ridiculous.
It's like Montana or something crazy.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
So lot of hippies though,
a lot of hippies,
but you don't see them.
They smell dude,
I was sick,
I was walking,
but there's a lot of fresh air,
so they're outdoors.
That's like a dirty dog.
It doesn't offend you.
Don't get that close to.
Exactly.
I was uh,
I was hiking up in the hills
in Topanga couple of weeks ago and I'm
sitting there on this trail taking,
uh,
taking in the view and I hear these two
guys coming up the trail and they can't
see me because there's,
you know,
a curve and they're talking and the one
guy says,
so are you feeling anything yet?
And the other guy's like,
well,
my legs feel a little funny,
but you know,
either he took Viagra and they're going
to go to the woods to fuck.
I didn't even occur to me.
I don't know.
I don't know why it occurred to you.
You ready to do this or feel anything
yet?
He loosening up.
Yeah,
it was a bit that he used to do,
but edibles.
Whereas like the worst thing you could
ever hear someone say I've taken out of
hole is I don't feel shit.
I'm gonna.
Take another one.
I don't do that.
It's always the case,
right?
When people just feel it.
Not really.
We'll go one more fuck it.
And then an hour and a half later you're
in terror.
Just a deep,
deep state of terror.
Yeah.
I was called in to consult on a case in
Spain with a guy that was in a mental
hospital and I'm the psychiatrist who
was treating him was a friend of mine
and knew that I took a lot of drugs and
this guy didn't,
hadn't taken any drugs,
so he's like,
could you just come in and like talk to
this guy and see what you think,
you know.
So I meet with the guy and I'm like,
so what's your story,
man?
He's like,
well look,
I was in Amsterdam and I ate a Brownie
and I wasn't feeling anything.
And so then I took these mushrooms and
you know.
And next thing I know I woke up,
I was in the jail cell naked.
I started walking down this.
Apparently they told me I was screaming
and singing it.
I was like,
so are you all right man?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm fine,
but everyone thinks I'm crazy because of
this thing.
And it's just like I get.
I keep telling him it's deal like the
guy from the Tom Berenger mother.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I talked to my.
Are you guys flying?
The guy's not crazy.
He just like ate too many fucking
brownies in Amsterdam.
It happens to everybody,
but if you eat brownies too many
brownies and mushrooms together,
but they work together though.
That's one of the interesting things
about marijuana and psilocybin.
They're very complimentary.
Like that was what Mckenna used to do
when he would take a mushroom trip,
he would eat the mushroom and then he
would wait for it to kick in and while
he was waiting for it to kick in,
he would roll joints and so he would
just roll a shitload of joints and then
just start smashing the joints and then
the marijuana would sort of like reach
out and grab the silicide that and
embrace it and just create this tornado
of awesomeness and that's how we used to
trip and he used to do it by himself.
Mckenna's thing was about silent
darkness.
Really concerned with experiencing the
psychedelic state in a very undisturbed
manner.
Like to him,
the idea of taking mushrooms going to
amusement was insane.
He had no desire to do anything like
that.
It just wanted to figure out.
And I think,
what is the quote?
Each time he would try to see how much
more he could stand and he would do that
for a while.
Maybe he was describing another guy when
he's talking about that now that I think
about it,
but he was a,
like a proponent of five dried grams.
He would.
He called it heroic dose.
Yeah.
That fucking heroic dose got me in
trouble.
I was reading Mckenna and I got this
acid from a friend of mine that I can't
talk about where it came from,
but it was like one of these sources
where it's like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
Like really from that source.
Okay.
Right from Albert Hoffman's lab pretty
much that kind of thing.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
[inaudible] like I'm used to be very
embedded in that world of like
scientists who were doing hallucinogenic
research and stuff.
Anyway.
So I,
I can't tell the whole story,
but I,
I decided to take a heroic dose because
it was like,
Eh,
I'm not going to do a lot more acid in
my life.
Might as well,
like go out with a bang,
and I took the stuff and how much you
take,
whether it was liquid a.
funnily enough,
what happened was I,
this psychiatrist who was a friend of
mine,
he hadn't done any drugs since the
sixties.
Back in the days when you could order
acid from Sandoz and they'd send it to
you,
Jesus Christ.
How long did that last?
That lasted until it was made illegal in
64,
something like that.
I thought it was all.
What didn't lsd go down with that
sweeping psychedelic acts of 1970 or
could've been later.
Was that maybe lsd went down before that
went on afterwards?
I don't know.
There was a bunch of them that were made
illegal in 70.
Even ones that aren't even
Nixon.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
in any case they,
you know,
it was marketed.
LSD was marketed to doctors and two
psychiatrists and psychologists who
would take it in order to experience
psychosis so they could better treat
their patients.
It was called a psychotomimetic,
so you could just order it and take it
and like,
oh,
this is what it's like to be psychotic
and understand that,
but you think about,
I mean from a medical perspective,
think about the nobility of that,
like what a cool doctor and what an
interesting time where it was like,
hey,
we all need to experience nine hours of
insanity,
so that will be better.
Or psychiatrist.
That's a pretty fucking cool thing.
That is very cool.
Very cool way of looking at it,
right?
Yeah.
It's a lifeguard who jumps into the
water and not a lifeguard who stands on
the beach and throws you a pill,
you know?
Yeah.
If you talk to a psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist doesn't have any
psychedelic experiences,
you you can understand it because you
know,
especially if you're an academic,
you want to be respected.
Psychedelic experiences for the most
part are illegal and you know,
people get weird about it and I can
understand wanting to keep it under
wraps,
but if you're not really interested in
it at all,
how much are you studying the mind?
Exactly and you not.
Experiential evidence is invalid.
I mean,
come on.
It's very valid.
We know that there's some extreme
effects that happen with some very
potent psychedelics.
Like,
um,
uh,
was a sage.
What is,
what is it called?
What are they called?
Salvia.
Salvia divinorum,
which is essentially sage,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
that stuff will blow your fucking mind.
And that shit was available in head
shops just a few years.
One of the most potent psychedelics
known to man,
I think it was Ari who had.
He did it and he,
he had a life.
He lived a whole life,
like three years.
He felt like he lived a life.
He had friends,
he had girlfriends.
He broke up with him.
He had jobs like the whole deal,
that matrix.
And then he came back and he was only
gone for like 10 minutes on this couch
on a Salvia trip.
Do we isolate that?
A clip?
Is that what you're looking for?
Yeah,
it.
There's a clip of him doing it and then
he talked about what happened later.
I think it was with you.
Yeah.
I want to dunk into podcasts,
but here's the clip of him doing it.
Yeah.
Brian's old podcast,
naughty show,
Sam Tripoli's podcast on Brian's death
squad network.
And so he uh,
res.
So he's gone there and they're all
laughing and talking.
Hee Hee,
ha ha.
Well this guy's trip and his balls off
like he's in another dimension.
Tell him I tell him.
Take him off.
I'm not joking.
I'm serious actually.
You're fine.
You're fine buddy.
Get away
from him.
We'll leave him alone.
Oh my God.
He was tripping so hard.
Did he think he was like suffocating?
I don't know at that.
Explains the Turlock podcast during the
podcast.
He explained it suffering there,
but what happened is they just probably
talking too much and it probably snapped
out of it and it was in the middle of
this haze of reality and the illusion.
I think doing something like that,
like you got to be around people who are
going to be quiet,
you know,
when you do it,
you know they're quiet and when they do
it,
you're quiet.
Sit there.
Yeah,
I did.
Uh,
after I saw you,
I saw you about a year ago.
I think I went from here to Mexico.
I went to that Ibogaine
clinic in Tijuana.
Ah,
you did?
Huh?
I didn't do the experience.
I want to see what it was like.
Yeah.
I was doing a podcast with a doctor who
works there and I met some people down
there who had,
um,
five meo DMT,
the painter or the toad thing.
And I did that.
That was a,
that was really intense.
I'd never done dmt before.
I asked her but never smoked dmt five.
Mel was the really weird stuff because
it's very empty.
You,
you go away,
you go,
you go to the center of the university,
become everything I guess.
Yeah.
How strong.
I mean,
how much of a dose did you get?
Did you blast off?
Blast it off?
Did you feel like that?
Like you were gone the first few minutes
or you know,
who knows how many minutes or time,
whatever,
but the first period,
yeah,
there was that sort of ego dissolution
where it's not me having this
experience,
it's just fucking experience right now.
It's just what it is.
Just colors and shapes and around holy
fuck.
Right.
But that in my case,
and this just reminded me of it,
watching already there,
in my case,
what happened was I got overwhelmed by
sadness like I've because people,
some people I'm close to are going
through really heavy shit in the last
couple of years and you know,
you sorta,
you feel compassion and you check in
with them and you,
you compassion literally means to feel
together.
Right?
And so you feel that with them.
But on another level it's like I'm not
the one who's got ms,
you know,
I'm not the one who's got chronic pain
and suffering all this shit.
Um,
so there's a separation.
But what I experienced with that was the
absence of separation.
And I was just immersed in the sadness
of people I love and you know,
seeing them suffering and not being able
to help them.
And it was overwhelming man.
I mean I cried like a baby literally.
Wow.
And uh,
and then I started coming out of it and
the room was quiet and he was
candlelight and all this and the person
who was sort of overseeing it was really
nice and you know,
sort of,
okay,
you're starting to feel better now and
here's the tissue and whatever.
And then the music came on and my first
thought,
my first conscious thought was,
remember when I write the yelp review of
this experience to mention that the
music should be different because the
music sucked.
It was shit,
new age shit music.
And I was like,
if you're going to play music,
play some fucking Bach or something,
play some Yani or whatever the fuck this
is.
But my,
you know,
I,
not that I use yelp a lot,
but it was just sort of like,
you know,
remember to mention this.
This could improve the experience for
other people.
You know what the,
what a weird way of thinking.
That's a very weird way of thinking.
So I had like this super profound
experience encased in the
most trivial bullshit imaginable.
I guess.
Stan hope.
Did that five Meo dmt back when you
could buy it online.
Yeah.
And he did it at my place.
We did it together,
but he had never done it before.
I had done it a few times when he and I
did it and he did it and I've never seen
anybody get hit by it harder.
Like he literally,
he was like slumped on my couch and he
was making.
He was groaning like it was,
it was disturbing.
It was.
So,
it was so extreme that I was wondering
like,
I knew that this is something that the
human body makes.
I knew that it's one of the most
transient drugs ever observed in the
body.
Your body brings it back to baseline
really quickly,
but not at that dosage.
It,
he didn't take that much in,
take any more than I took,
but it hit him like a Goddamn mack
truck.
And uh,
he came out of it and he just kept
saying,
life,
life just becomes life and then eats
life becomes life and just life just
becomes,
this just goes on.
It just goes on,
goes on.
Who's no denying that.
He's just looking at me like,
wow,
I go,
you tripped balls.
But I was worried.
I was like,
I can't kill my friend.
I was literally word for a few minutes.
I was like,
what of his body just can't handle it.
Like,
because Doug is world famous for abusing
himself,
cigarettes and booze and it's just
fucking,
he's got hernias.
You could stick out.
He can flex his stomach and things that
pop out of his gun.
I'm not bullshitting.
He's hilarious.
But you know,
he's a maniac.
He's just,
there's not a game man.
He's not playing an act as doug that he
is who he is.
And I was thinking maybe this is like
slapping a corvette engine into a 1969
dodge dart that's got 299,000
miles and just share wheels on the back,
bad breaks.
And it just seemed like,
well,
what have I done?
I shot up to it because when I did it,
it felt like I got shot through a
cannon.
It was like,
like the,
the experience of the launch,
like it came on slow,
like it came on,
like it took a few seconds and then once
it hit itches it's almost like you're
pulling back against a catapult band or
a rubber band or slingshot and just.
And then it was just flying to know me.
So like where I flew to,
there was no me,
there was no difference between me and
the air that's in front of me and the,
the wood that makes this table and the
floor beneath and all the different
molecules and atoms I could broke down
the existence of everything to some
strange geometric level and it was
really intense and totally colorless.
It's like a big white thing,
like it would bring you to this weird
geometric white thing.
Whereas DMT is come n n
dimethyltryptamine is five,
methoxy dimethyltryptamine is five meo
and it's just a different visual
experience than n n dimethyltryptamine,
which was the one that brings you these
intense visions of geometric patterns
and dancing.
Like the last time I did it it was they
were dancing jokers that were giving me
the finger.
They just kept giving me the finger and
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I deserve that.
Like I felt it,
like as they were doing it,
they're like,
fuck you,
fuck you.
And I was realizing like,
oh,
someone needs to say that to me.
Like,
oh,
I'm being silly person.
Like by even trying to control this
trip,
like by even like thinking that like I'm
just going to go into this.
I've been doing,
I'm been a good boy,
but doing my yoga and eating healthy and
this should be a good good trip.
Fuck you.
It was like,
fuck you.
You've got no control out of this.
You better relaxed,
which makes it a heroic dose.
You gotta let go.
Well,
all DMT is a heroic dose.
Once you passed that three hit
threshold,
right?
Good bye.
You're gone.
There's no,
there's no,
no,
you're gone.
You're gone or you're gone.
They're just gone.
Yeah.
That heroic dose I took,
I ended up.
I mean the story was a lot of weird shit
how he never got done explaining how
much did it actually take four hits.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah,
because I gave this old psychiatrist
three hits and I saw him a couple of
weeks later and he was like,
oh,
that was good clean stuff.
No problem.
It was,
and I thought,
well if that guy he's in his sixties
could take three.
I'll take four.
I met this dude in Montana recently,
very nice guy named Jeff and he was
working with us on this mediator show
and he's told us that he took 25 hits of
acid one night.
See I,
I went back in the day.
I did five or six or whatever,
but I felt like there was a plateau,
like I couldn't trip any harder than I
tripped.
So I,
I don't know that 20 would be.
Yeah,
he just went with it.
He said,
I forget how he described it,
but just went with it.
I just,
last night I watched this documentary
called the sunshine makers,
about the guys Owsley and,
and the two guys who were making orange
sunshine together,
the famous acid of the sixties.
Oh yeah.
And one of the guys was like,
that's all.
Send those.
Right.
That's all Sandoz lamps.
No,
that was the legal shit.
And so this is the guys in California
and Colorado briefly who were making the
illegal stuff.
Um,
and who,
who was in the sunshine,
I forget.
There's two guys.
The one guy was a ghost champions.
Got.
It.
Was a documentary.
Nicholas Tim scully,
unlikely duo at the heart of the 19
sixties American drug countercultural.
Yeah,
it's quite good.
It's so weird that that was so
incredibly recent,
but within a few decades they had
basically erased all evidence of it from
culture except for a few fringe people,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
talking about old research,
there were thousands,
tens of thousands of scientific papers
published on how hallucinogens affect
the brain.
In fact,
the Sarah Turner Jack System,
the whole understanding of
neurotransmitters really
was fueled by trying to understand how
so little lsd could make you so high.
That's what,
that's what got people into looking at
neurotransmitters in the effects on
consciousness in the late fifties
anyway.
I mean,
we could talk for ever about how a
hallucinogens have changed culture.
But uh,
what the hell was I saying?
Oh,
so you took forehead and the movie this
guy says,
yeah,
but the movie this guy says,
um,
you know,
he's talking about how they're doing the
vats and he's a chemist.
He's like,
every once in a while you know,
you touch something and it's hot and you
go,
Oh,
and you put your thumb in your mouth.
And I'm like,
oh,
I just took 200 micrograms of LSD.
They go,
well,
they were high all the time while they
were working.
Yeah.
And that's actually 22,000
La isn't there like a number?
Like someone told me,
this is maybe one of those urban myths,
like you have to register your hands as
lethal weapons once you get your black
belt.
That was an urban with too,
but isn't there an urban myth that like
if you do a certain amount of acid,
you're considered legally insane?
I heard that.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's true.
I hope it is because then I'm like free
and clear.
Let me see.
Jamie's at real.
That's what I've heard that my whole
life as well.
Do you remember hearing that?
It's bullshit.
I was like seven hits and make you
insane.
You're gone bro.
Legally.
So anything you do afterwards,
if you can prove you tripped at least
whatever,
seven times.
People that have done big doses of acid
and some of them have had a really hard
time grasping regular reality and I
wonder if there's a correlation.
I wonder if there's a connection between
like some of them have like really
distorted perceptions of what's going on
right now in terms of like,
like an experience will happen and
they'll have a version of the experience
and you'll relay your version of that
experience and they didn't.
They didn't remember that at all and
you're like,
man,
I don't know who's got this right,
because memory is kind of a slippery
thing,
but I don't remember him saying that to
you,
man.
I don't remember someone doing that to
you.
I don't remember that going down.
Like people have these weird perceived
interactions that maybe are a little
skewed and I always wonder like,
is it the 39 hits of acid you took one
night?
Is it,
I mean,
did you blow a fuse?
Can you blow a few of these in it?
Like you know,
somebody who works out and they mess up
their back and you say,
well you can blame it on working out or
you could blame it on and working out
wrong or you could blame it on the fact
that you probably already had a
structural issue in your back that this
just uncovered.
So I think a lot of people who have bad
experiences or end up fucked up from
hallucinogens,
they're going to be fucked up anyway.
And there are psychotic breaks.
You know,
like this kid that I talked about
earlier,
Nance Amsterdam,
he had a psychotic break,
but generally you can recover from that
and you'll be fine unless there's some
underlying structural issue in your
personality.
You know,
so I don't know.
I think it's multifactorial like
everything.
And so ultimately I think you're totally
right.
That completely makes sense and it's one
of the things that you've got to think
about when you talk about food or
alcohol or anything that people want up
getting addicted to,
right?
People
can blow their brains out on a variety
of different substances that are readily
available.
We're always looking for the reason for
the effect,
but normally it's a million reasons for
an effect,
but it's no constellation if your son
goes crazy from taking acid,
you know,
it's one of those things if acid became
legal and your son walked into a cvs and
bought acid and did too much with his
friends and never came back and you had
to take care of him when he's 50.
No,
it's no constellation.
But you know,
a lot of people have psychotic breaks
when their girlfriend breaks up with
them the first time.
It's true.
So are we going to blame women for
psychosis?
You know,
it's hard to describe or to really
recognize like what is a psychotic
break,
what is real mental illness and when are
you just being a bitch?
Well,
a professional should be able to
recognize.
I would hope so.
At least when you're just being near an
edge,
during an edge to like mental illness
and just being a bench like we're
talking about.
Psychosis.
Neurosis.
One more time,
dude,
don't call her.
I've got to call her.
No you don't.
You don't have to call it.
The universe was telling me to call her.
I have to talk to her right now.
She'll understand what's her talked to
her.
There is a restraining order.
Stop.
Do you want to go to jail?
I'm just going to knock on our window.
Don't do it.
There's people that get obsessed with
people when it comes to relationships
and you just go,
what will people get addicted to each
other?
They get as addicted to each other as
they get addicted to sugar easily.
It's harder for people to break up with
people than it is from the kick.
Sugar people can kick sugar.
They decide they want to lose weight.
A lot of people do it,
but when people break up like the
emotional toll that you take,
it's so devastating and I think part of
the reason why the emotional toll so
devastating and less being with the
person was completely negative.
It was completely negative.
Then you're like,
finally,
I'm fucking free.
I've met a few of those in my life and
I'm sure you have to,
but there's other ones.
We like,
God,
this feels terrible,
and it's like it's stuck a emotional
flu.
No,
it doesn't want to go away,
and I think it's because we get addicted
to each other in the same way that we
bonded to create these communal tribes
have 50 people back in the day.
Those instincts still remain and I think
one of the reward systems,
and you would know better than I have
connecting everybody together with this
is got to be this deep affection and
this addiction that we developed towards
each other.
Yeah,
well,
we,
we need to be loved.
We need to be touched.
And a lot of times if you don't have a
partner,
nobody's touching,
you know,
as an adult.
And uh,
yeah,
I mean I love is a funny thing.
I talk about this a lot on the podcast,
you know,
I guess I'm.
People think I'm some sort of
relationship expert,
which is hilarious.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I told this,
I don't know if I've told this story in
your podcast,
but my dad has this golden retriever and
he's had like five of them.
They all look the same.
I don't know this one,
just the last one thing,
brandy.
Okay.
So the fourth of July
they had the dog out in the backyard and
they went to watch some fourth of July
things,
some party somewhere.
And apparently the fireworks scared the
dog and the dog jumped a fence and took
off.
Oh No,
and so my dad and my sister were all
freaked out and they're putting up store
signs all over the neighborhood and
Colin and the shelters and all that day
or two later,
they get a call from shelter.
Hey,
we've got your dog come down and like,
oh,
there she is,
so take the dog home.
They're in the backyard throwing the
ball with the dog,
and my sister's boyfriend comes home and
he looks out the window and he says to
my mom,
who's dog are they play in with?
She said,
well,
that's brandy.
And he said,
that's not brandy.
And then a few minutes later the phone
rings.
It's a neighbor.
Hey,
we've got brandy.
Oh Jesus,
it's the wrong dog.
Right?
So what do they do?
They took it back to the found should
killed it.
Your imposter.
You try to pretend you're not branding,
respond to brandy fraud,
but my point,
yeah,
no,
the dog was like,
what did I do wrong?
I chased your ball.
You know,
I mean,
they were.
They sound like a great dog owner.
They should have just kept that.
She brought it back.
They found of exactly where you adopt a
kid and again,
I'm going to send you back.
Yeah.
If somebody comes looking for that dog,
then call me until then.
The dog lives here.
Should have been.
You can't bring it back.
The power.
What a fucking drag for the dog.
I know,
but my point is there in the backyard
with the dog.
What are they feeling?
My Dad's feeling incredible relief.
Brandi's back love.
He loves brandy,
brandy,
but it doesn't matter because he's still
feeling love and I think we do that in
our relationships.
We project our need to love on whoever
the fuck will take it.
I mean,
what's that Beatle Song?
I need somebody to love and then in the
back you ever listed in the back,
they see can it be anybody?
And then he says,
I just want someone to love.
I don't give a fuck who it is.
I just want a dog.
I don't care.
I want a girlfriend.
Take whatever.
What do you do?
That's a thing with a lot of people that
don't have relationships.
They have a bunch of pets.
Yeah,
they need someone or something.
I love anytime.
You know,
if you're a single person,
you come home,
your dogs are so happy to see you really
couldn't your kisses in get your pets
in.
Yeah,
I mean dogs are like emotional bandaids
for a lot of people.
Even cats,
you have cats.
I love cats and they don't give a fuck.
Don't give a fuck.
Are you there or not?
But they'll sit on your lap and purr
when you pet them.
Yeah,
they'll accept your love,
which is nice.
Sometimes that's enough dogs better
obviously,
you know,
I can't believe you can get new cats.
Fucking shows sucks,
right?
I forget where they are.
The millions of listening and it's just
such a hackneyed debate.
Dogs versus cats.
I'm really into fucking aardvarks bro.
Pet aardvark.
Yeah.
I watched a video
online of a wild pig that had eaten
through a cow's body and got stuck in
the farmer,
found the cow and this wild pig is like
coming out through a hole in its
stomach,
like he'd eaten through the cow and got
stuck.
It's like Jim Carrey and pet detective
when he comes out of the Zebra.
Is this it?
Yeah,
there it is.
You watch a lot of gross shit,
but this is not that gross.
See,
look at it.
It's stuck.
I can't get out of the body,
the skin,
the skin of the cow at eight through it,
but then it can't get fat body through
and got his head through,
but he can't fit the rest of it through.
How could it not back out.
Doesn't know what to do with stupid
fucking wild pig.
I have a friend who has a pig.
A pet pig.
A potbelly pig.
Yeah,
exactly it.
Apparently he passed.
It's like really smart.
Yeah.
It's a bummer if there's a little
bacon's a bummer.
If you think about what is it is.
I keep trying to find cruelty free bacon
and it's just not.
They're not real.
I can't find you got to shoot a pig.
Get Bacon.
Just a certain amount of cruelty
involved in that delicious Taylor here.
A pig or see a pink dye.
I've killed pigs.
Cope.
They don't die.
Happy.
Well,
I.
The one I killed died real quick,
shot it with a 300 win mag and died
instantly in the head,
in the body body cavity like blue.
It's hard out,
but he died instantaneously.
Turned around.
I drove a 300 the scope into my
forehead.
That was nice.
Got a lot of kick.
It's a good round because anything it
hits dies very humanely,
very quickly if you hit it right,
obviously.
Yeah,
but I'm wild.
Pigs are a huge problem and I know that
pig people have a problem with people
eating animals and I get that,
but there's always going to be an issue.
Even if we didn't need any animals.
If you don't want all of your vegetables
eaten up by wild pigs,
somebody has to control the population
because there's no way to control them.
They breed at a staggering rate.
They breed three or four.
I mean they'll have these letters.
They can have literally two,
three times a year.
They started having litters when they're
six months old,
when they're six months old,
they start shitting out pigs and there's
a ton of them.
I mean,
there's around Sonoma county.
I've been in San Jose,
they're eating people's lawns and
residential neighborhoods.
They're not to be fucked with you.
Don't get outta here.
Pig.
They'll kill your dog to the fuck your
dog up and slice them up and they'll eat
them too.
Once he's dead.
Their tusks,
like especially the big boars,
they're enormous animals too.
You're talking about like some of them
were.
They shot one at that to hone.
Ranch thing was about 350 pounds last
week.
Three hundred 50 pounds for.
This is a wild snorting,
horrific beast.
It's not a fat pig wallowing around
there.
Fast and aggressive.
They're fast,
aggressive and ferocious.
They have a what's called a a shield
plate all around their front body,
like where their face is like from their
jaw line back.
They have this incredibly thick like
leather and it's to protect them from
going to war with other male bores in
those giant tusks,
so they fucking slice each other up and
so these things are just their tanks.
They're super durable tanks who are born
at a ridiculous rate if there's millions
of them roaming through the country.
And there was an article that I posted
on twitter just a few days ago where,
uh,
the scientists were saying it's just a
matter of time before every county in
every state has a wild pig problem.
It's just there.
They're not stopping the breeding and
not stopping the growth and they're just
going to slowly spread out like coyote
roadies
and the meat's good,
right?
Oh,
it's really good.
It's delicious.
The perfect situation because you're,
you're killing something that needs to
be killed,
you know,
it used to be cougars were killing them
and you know,
whatever other predators we're keeping
them in check.
There's no not,
they're an invasive species.
They weren't native to North America.
Now they're brought over here from
Russia.
They were brought over here from Asia.
They brought over here from different
parts of the world are some ferocious
Russian ones that are in the northern
California coast that are connected to,
I think it was William Randolph hearst,
the hearst castle up there.
I think William Randolph hearst had
bores up there.
It's one more thing they came from,
there were predators,
you know,
well,
the Siberia,
they,
you know,
they probably lived in incredibly harsh
environments and it's one of the reasons
why they thrive here.
Yeah.
And my point is there's no Predator now
they're living free.
They're not,
they're not like pigs that are turned
into bacon or fucking cages where they
can turn around and all that shit.
See,
that's the thing that gets me.
I mean,
I have no problem eating meat because as
Doug Stanhope said,
life becomes life.
You know,
life eats life.
That's what it does.
There's no getting around that.
There's a book called the Vegetarian
Myth.
You ever read that?
Um,
yes.
It was a woman who was a Vegan for 20
years and then she's like,
I'm going to grow my own food.
And as soon as she started growing her
own food,
she realized there's no way to even grow
food without killing stuff.
You got to put this stuff down to
protect the garden from the slugs and
kills the slugs.
The fertilizer is made out of bone and
blood meal.
Where's that come from?
Right.
It's like there's no way to not kill
things in order to eat.
Even if you're eating vegetables,
you still killing things to eat them.
Well,
that's the connection to the actual food
itself.
Rate right from the source and it gives
you this understanding of it,
but still you can,
you can mitigate the amount of suffering
that you've asked.
What I was going to say.
Yeah.
I've got no problem eating something
that lived a life,
a free life.
Like these wild boars.
Yeah.
What I have a problem with is the
industrial process,
you know,
wild boar is,
might be one of the few things that we,
um,
we almost have enough where everybody
can hunt them because I mean there's not
enough deer.
There's not enough elk for people to,
to hunt in this country.
Like if everybody wanted to do what some
people are trying to do with it,
just trying to get all the meat from the
wild does it just not enough wild but
there enough for the amount of people
that are doing it for sure.
Definitely it's a very sustainable,
but that's also why it's really
difficult to get certain tags for
certain animals in certain areas where
they do monitor the population and they
say,
well we have like a certain amount here,
this is a,
this is the amount that we have and this
is the amount that we think would be
healthy to removed from the population
because of the competition for food and
this and that and,
and you know,
so these people compete for not to
compete,
but they put it in there for like the
apply for a tag,
like a lottery system.
It might be a thousand people apply,
but only 100 get tags and now those 100,
most of the time it's not even 50
percent success rate.
So these are the proposition of going
out and just trying to get your own
meats.
Very sketchy.
It's very hard to do.
Not everybody could do it.
So it's not,
it's not really a viable alternative to
feeding 350 million people.
No,
but it could be viable for you.
And I feel like that's the thing about
people when it comes to impact.
We always,
we have this weird thing,
we're go,
well,
everybody can't do that.
You're right.
Everybody can do that.
Everybody can't live in your house
either,
right?
Everybody doesn't want to do that.
Everybody can't sleep in your bed.
Every.
Everybody can't fuck your wife unless
you guys would like that,
unless your brakes,
you know,
it's like there's a certain amount of
shit you can think of for your own life,
like for your own life.
You want to feel better?
Go shoot a wild pig.
That's where you get your food.
You'll feel better.
You'll feel weird.
You.
Michael Pollan wrote a very interesting
essay about him shooting a wild pig up
in sonoma.
It's,
I think it's included in the Omnivore's
dilemma,
his big best seller where he wanted to
trace the origins of everything,
every element of a meal.
And so he built a book around that.
But he,
I remember reading that essay in the New
Yorker,
I think.
And um,
I was struck by how he,
he conveys really powerfully the feeling
of having killed something where there
was this sort of jubilation followed by
shame,
followed by like a confusion and
discussed and like all these things were
sort of waves passing through him.
You know,
he wasn't a big hunter.
He just wanted to have this one
experience.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
it's my buddy,
Justin's gonna take me hunting.
He's been offering for a couple of years
now and I want to do it.
I'm not a big killer,
but I know how to shoot guns and I feel
some responsibility to face the reality
of meat,
you know?
I mean just face it,
you're killing shit,
you know,
and just because someone's doing it for
you in a factory and cutting it up and
putting it in plastic,
that doesn't mean you're not involved in
that process.
Would you be one of the people that
would adopt lab created meat?
Would you put that in your diet once
that,
that actually happens because they're
pretty sure that they're going to be
able to make that happen soon?
Or would you look at it and say,
well,
I mean,
how would you look at it?
I'd want to look at it scientifically
and no,
you know,
what's the nutritional content?
Because I'm very suspicious of these
things that come out of laboratory.
Yeah.
But if it turned out that it was,
it tasted the same,
the nutritional content was as good as
wild,
you know,
meet with grass Fed Omega three and all
that kind of stuff.
They Omega three,
Omega six ratios were right?
Yeah,
I'd eat it.
Why not?
I eat a lot of weird shit and we all do.
Or most of us,
you know,
I would definitely try it.
My mother had a bowl of cheese puffs the
other day at the superbowl.
What the fuck is a cheese puff?
Asshole fire talk.
Something that comes out of a lab or
marshmallows when they have banned trans
fats in the United States,
but they allow people to put them in for
the next couple of years in 2018 runs
out.
So until then you could poison people.
Until then you can keep throwing that
stuff and whatever the fuck baked goods
and Taito creations.
What did we find out the Trans fats are
in?
It was in like microwave popcorn I think
was one.
That's crazy.
That stuff's God damn delicious.
Yeah,
I'd love microwave popcorn and what do
you need to make popcorn?
It's not.
I mean just make it normally a little
oil.
I know,
but it's so convenient.
If you're a lazy fuck,
it's the stockpiles you can do,
you know,
the whole sort of fertilizer and I'm not
fertilizer pesticide,
insecticide and you know,
farm spraying crops and all that shit.
That all started because at the end of
World War II there were huge stockpiles
of chemical weapons that weren't used.
And so they're like,
what are we going to do with this shit?
We gotta sell this shit.
And they were like,
well we can dilute it and spray it and
it'll kill aphids or whatever the fuck.
And there really wasn't a big problem
with pests in the American farming
industry,
but they had all the stock pile of
stuff.
And the Rachel Carson writes about this
in silent spring.
A classic book.
Yeah.
Crazy.
So it's like there's bacon and eggs.
We think that's a natural breakfast
thing that was invented by an
advertising agency.
Yeah.
We talked about this before.
Anyway.
Yeah.
We talked about this and we've talked
about how Kellogg's created really blend
cereal to keep people from beating off.
See,
that's my shtick.
Right.
That's a beautiful stick though.
Once people find out that's true.
You're like,
what?
Just think of how bizarre Graham
crackers Graham crackers again.
Again,
it was current.
Graham and Kellogg were the two sort of
anti masturbation guy and he thought
Graham crackers keep you from being off
because they're so blend.
That's hilarious.
Isn't it hilarious that they associated
spicy food,
like Latino's dance?
They had tacos.
We had to tell about the Taco.
Yeah,
some fucking hot salsa.
Salsa music.
Getting crazy.
You always associate salsa music with a
woman with like a dress.
It's like slit up the side.
Um,
and the way up to her hip.
See,
I wish if I were efficient like you,
I would have learned to salsa dance
years ago.
I'm not that efficient.
I don't see.
I can't even ice skate in your head.
There's salsa dancing and then right
next to it on the shelf is ice skating
seems to be something that a lot of
people know how to do.
Not a lot of Mexicans.
That's true of African ice skaters.
Right.
That's what black people have,
haven't dominated hockey otherwise.
Able to take it over.
That shit too.
I'm coming because ice skating like a
fucking never learned.
Yeah.
I can ice skate,
you know,
I feel good now.
My kids can but can.
But like to me the sexiest women or the
women who were salsa dancing,
you know,
like sweaty,
move the way they move and it's all
like,
well it's a party and I just love to be
out there on the floor.
Mr Coolguy a light colored suit,
you know?
Yeah.
Like Miami Vice.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what I'm picturing.
But first no socks you doing in my
dreams.
That's me problem with loafers.
No socks.
They could really stink after a while.
Right.
You can get your fetal sweat and air and
it's disgusting and it's not as much.
Yeah,
it's gross.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm lucky in that respect or I'm just
totally diluted,
but I think I.
I think my body does instinct much,
but I may be wrong about that.
I may just have really friendly people
around.
Well,
you know how olfactory senses work,
right?
They work on change.
They don't work on.
You don't recognize like distinct smells
that last,
like a say if you're living in an area
that stinks.
You know how people used to.
The smell of baby shit.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Not necessarily because baby shit's not
in front of you all the time,
but things that are around you all the
time,
like your own funk or how your house
smells,
your.
You become immune to it.
Unless there's like,
like if you have a house,
like if you're at a cat pissing your
house,
fucking my friend in bed.
Do you like walking around?
Like where the fuck is it?
Now I'm walking around like a God damn
dog trying to find out where my cat
pissed,
especially when I used to have a carpet
grows because you never knew where they
pissed and then you never really totally
got it out of there and then they know
you never got it out of there.
So they find that spot piano and again,
wretched a cat in college.
I'd moved into this shared apartment
with this woman and uh,
she had this cat named Michael who was
beautiful cat,
big,
big sort of whiskers and just a lovely,
beautiful of communism.
I don't know,
I think it was more like a thing,
but the cat would like get on a table
and he put his paws on your shoulders
and just rub his face and your face and
you'd be like,
oh,
what a great cat.
And then he would just freak out and
like fucking face and scratchy and run
away.
Like,
oh,
this cat fucked right.
Probably got acid.
Somebody fucking massive.
I think.
Yeah,
because it was one of these hippie
houses where people are moving through
all the time,
fucking hippies.
Anyway,
so I ended up hooking up with this woman
and I remember one time we were in my
bed and we're having sex and the cat
walks in and he looks at me and he backs
up to my bookshelf and just show my love
for my well holding eye contact with me.
Oh,
that's disturbing.
Uh,
I think he had a thing with this woman
and I was.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Just getting with her because he's
probably,
if he's spraying,
it's probably not fixed.
Right.
It wasn't fixed.
You cannot.
First of all,
you got to fix those cats because when
they walk in on you fucking they're
going to get horny if freaks.
Yeah.
Especially male cats that don't,
they don't get fixed.
They all spray.
All of them mean female cats.
They get into heat and they start
mowing,
sticking their ass up in the air.
Yeah.
I told the story about my sexual
experience to see the animation.
That guy did it that.
No,
I didn't.
Who did it?
Which guy?
Name?
But it's,
it's on youtube and it is.
So polly polly,
it's an animator in in Peru and he wrote
to me,
he's,
he's not Peruvian but he's based there,
but he wrote to me and he's like,
hey man,
would you mind if I did an animation of
some store,
a story you tell in your podcast?
I was like,
yeah,
go ahead.
That's great.
You don't need my permission.
Right.
But he picked the one of me and you and
Duncan and I'm telling the story about
this cat and the pencil and the cats up
in the pencil and all this shit.
It's like,
dude,
you pick the one story like I don't
really want the world.
Like the Joe Rogan audience will get it.
My audience will get it,
but I don't know that like twitter
universe is gonna get it.
So I feel bad because he put a lot of
work into it,
but I haven't really pushed to promote
it much.
But it's really what you're saying.
But I think your,
your fears are unfounded to think.
So that's the fuck the people don't have
you come across.
You're hilarious.
And the Jamie,
if you could find this thing.
It's called A.
It's on my youtube channel.
I remember the story.
It's something about if you just Google
Christopher Ryan fucks a cab with a
pencil or does it?
I'd love to see what else.
We had a catalyst and he,
before she got fixed,
we've got to fix like right when she got
into heat.
But when you had pet her and she was
like,
lift her ass up in the air.
Just like as soon as you give her any
affection and then it'll be spanker they
love to get spanked to Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I had a cat who would hold onto the sofa
and I'd spank or God.
And then I'd like fake spanker and she'd
fall off because she was already
compensating for it.
God.
So you were like beating her off by
spanking or you know,
I basically write,
I like to give animals pleasure.
And normally the way that expresses
itself,
like in Spain,
in our apartment in span,
I built this whole cat world like I
built.
I got this big piece of driftwood and I
wrapped.
I'm climbing rope around it so they can
climb straight up this thing and then
there's a series of shelves along the
ceiling so they jump around and they can
go all around the room and chase each
other and hang out up there.
When you're having a party,
they're like up there just hanging out
watching people and because they're,
you know,
that's where they want to be.
Right.
And then on the terrorist I built this
big tree thing,
they go on and there's a hammock in it
and the cats get in the hammock and
swimming.
And so I love seeing the animals happy,
you know?
I mean maybe in a way my whole,
my,
the things I write are trying to make
people happy because what I'm trying to
do is get people in their natural
environment.
That's what I'm trying.
This one I'm writing about,
you know.
And so with cats it's the same way I
want them to be.
I want them to.
I want to create a jungle for them and a
world.
And it's so cool because we had three
cats and they,
once you build this world for them,
they leave you alone.
They're not like.
People think cats are like,
ah,
you know,
it's all pathetic.
It's,
you know,
I come home and we ain't me man.
If you have three cats,
they have their own life and they're
happy to interact with you when you went
to.
But when you don't want to,
they're doing their thing,
you know?
It was really.
It's really good.
Alright.
Jamie arthritis there.
Interesting little animals,
man.
I love the relationships that people
have with their cats.
It's very.
Okay.
Here we go.
What is that?
Well,
don't,
don't watch the whole thing.
This one's got like a laugh track on it.
Oh No,
no,
no.
The laugh track.
He added that.
That's because I was talking about doing
this Gig in Hollywood.
Oh,
okay.
It's called a nine and a half lives with
Dr Christopher Ryan.
Why is it not?
But you should see the image of you
though.
You're sitting just like this.
There you go.
Let's hear some of it.
I'm eight years old.
It's the seventies and a bridge party at
their friend's place in it.
So there's no babysitter.
They take a station wagon and love
American style,
the Brady bunch those days,
if anyone's old enough to remember that
shit.
Anyway.
So I'm like,
Hey,
they put me in the basement in the
family room and they say keep the door
closed because the cats in heat,
right.
That means,
I think it means the cat part.
So they've got the AC on,
keep the door closed.
I don't know.
So I go down and watching TV and this is
just like all over the place,
rubbing her ass on my leg and just like
looking at me and she's like,
really?
Because somebody scratched my itch,
you know?
And I looked down and there's this
pencil on the table next to the sofa.
Oh No,
you did take the pencil and with the
eraser down,
I just hold it there.
Right.
And this cat backs up on this.
So it starts fucking humping.
Reached me out the inside of her.
Apart with the metal casing.
No,
no,
but you know what?
Male cat penises have spine that come
out on when the withdrawal that does rip
up the inside of the female blood has to
mix with catsimatidis fertilized staff.
What happened was the pencil away
because it was freaking me out and then
turns around and looks at me like,
Yo,
what?
Hey,
what are you doing that got to come on.
And like,
like really like shocked and
disappointed.
I was like Whoa.
So I put it back down again and the cab
backs up when it starts fucking this
pencil again and this time I hold on and
then she comes and she's a forecast and
she like rolls over and looks at me
looking at her face and it looks at me
with love and gratitude.
First sexual experience I ever had.
You didn't put your penis against the
cab was eight years old?
I wasn't.
I was experiencing it as an idea.
I wasn't feeling it as a sexual thing.
You?
Yeah.
When you were a kid,
but I could see that.
Oh I fucked every cat in the
neighborhood.
Did you?
Is that good to Dave Anderson?
Blood sausage.co
dot UK.
What?
Uh,
he's great animations,
amazing.
Perfect.
I mean,
I've probably seen it 20 times and every
time I see details,
if you freeze that frame of the Brady
Bunch or love American style or whatever
it was like every one of those
characters.
And I'd love to know how accurate his
tattoo is of your arm.
And do you have a tee shirt that says
how dare you?
No,
I don't.
It's just a phrase he used to say it all
the time.
I don't think the tattoos were accurate.
I didn't recognize him,
but whatever.
It was amazing.
The Duncan thing with little pyramid
with the floating high above it,
sitting in front of them all the time
and he's wearing a syrupy guys.
Great.
Yeah.
What is definitely not correct.
But um,
the uh,
the other thing was the car,
how the car was bouncing up and down as
he was driving and it's got the wood
siding,
you know,
it's like he,
he got the seventies,
everyone's wearing leisure suits and
smoking cigarettes.
A shit is really well done.
Not Matter.
What the fuck was that?
Oh,
we're talking about giving cats.
Pleasure making animals.
Had a buddy of mine who used to jerk off
as rottweiler with his foot.
He used to put his foot on his was dick
and he would like rub it back and forth
and rottweiler would come.
And uh,
I told my girlfriend at the time,
it's a long time ago and she was so mad.
She was so disgusted like that.
It's fucking disgusting.
And I'm just like,
why is it disgusting?
The guys just beaten off his dog,
like,
the dog can't do it.
The dog could do it.
He would do it himself.
So he's like a friend talking like his
own balls pretty easily.
Uh,
yeah,
that's true.
But I don't think that's enough.
I think you needed more.
So my friend needs to beat them off with
his foot.
His dog.
I think there's like a female sex toy.
You can get the dogs.
Oh yeah.
There's like a thing that,
that makes sense.
Like a fleshlight for dogs.
That makes sense.
Keep them from helping your leg.
Yeah.
Why not?
I mean,
you want them to be happy.
There was this controversy,
uh,
not too long ago,
a woman wrote a book about John Lilly,
Jamie,
just,
yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
And you look at this,
there is a doll to sex doll doll for
dogs and it's shaped like a dog and you
just got to get your horny dog and just
back them up onto that bitch.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Will push them forward onto that bitch.
Say back the bitch up onto him.
Well,
why don't they just make like a one of
them real dolls for a dog?
Give it hair.
Like the American Werewolf in London out
there.
Something like that with a dog.
Doesn't feel dirty.
Like he's got a flux of machine because
they didn't put any,
any work whatsoever in the aesthetics.
Do you think the dogs care?
They might.
It might feel better for them.
They might get a little more excited if
fluidly.
A real dawn.
You could give it like a soundtrack.
A little while.
Just looking over shoulder please.
Please don't.
Uh,
yeah.
With the woman who jerked off the
Dolphin.
Yes.
Well,
what's fascinating about that story is
this woman was living with a young
adolescent male dolphin in this
adolescent male.
Dolphin would.
They were trying to get the dolphin to
talk in a flooded house,
flooded house.
So she lived in a place where she would
like have waist high water everywhere
she went,
so the dolphin could swim freely through
the house and live with her.
But the dolphin was horny all the time.
So he didn't want to do studies.
So what she did was she beat him off and
when word got out that she beat off the
dolphin,
they canceled all the research is now
how I thought it.
The research.
Well,
they got in trouble,
the gunter,
but recently because she talked about it
recently when she wrote a book about the
time I was working with John Lilly who
run to invent this sensory deprivation
tank.
Well,
no,
he,
I think he had already been invented it
at the time.
He was on like one of the first
iterations of it and he was also giving
assets dolphins.
So it might've been.
That was one of those things that led to
them pulling the plug on.
The research is either she was jerking
it off and they found out that they were
also.
I think the Defense Department was using
his research to train dolphins to kill
in Vietnam and to plant bombs,
suicide bombs and suicide bombers.
They would try.
They were training them to suicide bomb,
which is crazy.
It's crazy that they.
They felt like that was.
Well I guess.
Look man,
when you were in war,
you were already deciding that you're
killing people,
so the,
the idea of killing dolphins to kill
people.
It's like they didn't think of dolphins
the way we think of dolphins today,
either like that.
That might be something that the
military would still be interested in
doing.
I don't know.
I mean maybe they aren't doing it.
They're just not telling us about it.
A lot of whales with all their sonar
testing.
Yeah,
because they do these intense sound
waves in the underwater and the whales
have very sensitive sound reception.
Oh,
organize.
So at fucking blast them and because it
gives them like tinnitus or some shit,
like a rock band.
The lead singer of Ac dc can't do shows
anymore.
Pete Townsend really can't hear
anything.
Pete Townsend's almost deaf too.
In depth for.
Yeah,
the lead singer of AC DC.
His ears are so fucked up.
He can't tour anymore.
Yeah.
I can't go to concerts,
man.
Like I.
I've been to a few concerts recently.
I mean I never.
It's not a question of being old.
I hear that getting older noise bothers
you more.
But I've always been annoyed by noise
and especially where they're playing
shit so loud that it's distorting the
speakers.
It's like year.
That's not.
That doesn't sound good by being louder
is better,
but I don't know.
That's a weird.
Yeah.
But there's a thing that people like to
do.
They like to know that they're really
fucking party and man that's it.
Turn it up to 11 and I think those are
the people that need to go to the
fucking gym.
Heavy bag.
That's it.
See,
this is it.
This keys back into me being a lazy
Hippie,
like moderate sound,
but I don't need it to all the way out.
Get something to beat up.
You fucks.
Yeah.
And stopped it out.
So you never been to the Salton sea?
No,
I have not.
But I saw that you were there recently.
I was a photo.
Yeah.
It should come out there.
I want to.
It's an intense post apocalyptic scene
out to just see the joy.
It was John Waters to the documentary
on,
I believe.
No,
no,
no.
There was a scene in,
into the wild where he,
the kid is there.
Do you remember that?
He's hanging out with some hippies and
like a desert that was in the salt and
sea.
Yeah.
He was in slab city,
which is in the solvency.
Oh yeah.
I've got my buddy towel as a this year.
Is the second a Bombay beach being
alley.
He's doing.
Oh,
look at that.
That guy.
Salvation Mountain.
That's that guy that has been making
this mountain.
Yeah.
Out of a art and painting it for years.
It's all about Jesus and love.
And He,
uh,
he makes his paint and Straw and mud and
he built this whole thing.
Yeah.
It's crazy structure has been working on
for decades,
right.
He died a couple of years ago.
Oh,
thought is that Kristen Stewart?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Her Dad used to be the,
uh,
one of the,
the producer guys on fear factor.
He was like,
I don't know what his official title
was,
but he was like the guy who got
everything together,
like got everybody in place and made
sure everything was running.
It was like big job.
Yeah.
He was like the guy on the street,
like while everything was going on,
really good dude.
Fun Guy.
Crazy man.
And that's,
uh,
that's his daughter.
And I was always like,
dude,
you shouldn't have your kid act.
She's so young.
It seems crazy.
So we'll never make it.
While she was a twilight girl,
seemed like one of the most famous
actresses,
but I never saw her until Saturday night
live a couple of days ago.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So on,
like we should do it.
She hosted.
Oh no kidding.
This last.
Yeah.
Just got some new movie coming out or
something.
I don't know what she was doing.
Know what she was promoting.
If anything,
I didn't catch it.
I just watched it because the scene with
Kathy Bates Doing Sean Spicer.
Did you see that?
No,
but I heard it was awesome.
I haven't seen this.
Meghan McCarthy.
Macarthur.
Thank you.
I keep saying Kathy Bates,
it's thing.
It's negative mccarthy.
It's Melissa Mccarthy Directing your
current.
Jamie.
I think that that's show Saturday night
live is all the evidence we need.
The Donald Trump needs to do mushrooms
because he keeps tweeting about Alec
Baldwin doing that sketch about them
saying it's not funny to.
Why are we laughing?
Tell me what's going on.
Like if someone shitting on you.
Look,
it doesn't feel good.
I know.
It doesn't feel good,
but it is funny.
Yeah.
You know,
and Alec Baldwin does do a fucking
amazing impressionable.
It's his best work,
right?
It's right up there with that whole
fucking closers.
Get coffee.
Oh,
a Glengarry Glen Ross.
Glen Ross.
Yeah.
Been that rant that he did in that
movie.
That's insane.
Fucking epic,
right?
Yeah,
I think there's trump impressions right
up there.
Yeah,
it's really good.
It's really good and it's getting
better.
The more he does,
he looks more and more like him,
you know,
what does it say?
They're bad news for trump side.
I live in the midst of a ratings
renaissance.
Of course it is,
and that's one of the reasons why,
you know,
the center live is like a show that goes
in cycles,
you know,
you have these cycles of greatness and
then like to try to find themselves,
believe new people struggle a little
bit.
There's always something good there,
but it's almost like a,
it's really,
it's got to be insanely difficult to
create a new show every week.
Insane.
You know,
dog eat dog environment and even like
you look,
if you go back and look at videos from
the glory days,
you know,
that Dan Akroyd days and John Belushi
and all that,
there was still a lot of filler in
there.
Oh,
for sure.
You know,
we remember the automatic and you know,
the good,
the great moments.
A Samurai John Belushi,
Sandra character.
Exactly.
You couldn't do that anymore.
It'd be cultural appropriation that you
couldn't do.
You probably couldn't do the.
Were too wild and crazy guys.
I don't know.
I mean they were right.
They were white,
but there were definitely foreign
because you do more at.
Could you do bar out today?
I don't know.
I mean it was just a few years ago,
but it might be different if he tried it
today.
Incredibly racist and he's like,
oh,
he's like an Orthodox Jew.
That guy,
the comedian who does Bora.
Is He really?
Yeah.
He's like a seriously religious,
you know,
honors this Shabat and all that kind of
stuff.
Serious Jewish practicing Jew.
I forgot his real name is Ali g to me,
Ali.
Jesus' best work when he would interview
people and they didn't know who his leg.
He can't do that anymore.
But when he interviewed me,
he interviewed a Buzz Aldrin,
explained humor to him.
That was one of the greatest.
He's explaining humor while he's in the
midst of a joke that he doesn't know is
for buzz or owned.
Yeah.
But you know who my favorite,
uh,
one of the few where he wasn't getting
on with Ralph Nader,
Ralph Nader just kind of went with him.
Well,
what happened was,
so allie is doing this whole thing where
they're talking about the environment
and global warming and he says,
well,
but you know,
isn't a major cause of global warming,
the cow farts.
And so shouldn't we just,
you know,
put balloons on cows and you know,
he gets into this whole thing,
right?
And Ralph Nader is looking at them and
you can see when the balloons on the
cows asses thing comes out.
Ralph Nader's like I go,
wait a minute.
And so he just sort of,
when he finished his talk and he says,
well,
you know,
scientists have been working on that,
but it's very hard to develop a valve
that perfectly fits a cow's ass hole.
And then it cuts,
cuts.
And then the next scene,
like after commercial,
whatever,
you see algae and Ralph Nader wrapping
together.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Is a really.
Do one of those with trump.
But trump walked out on us.
Play this very quick,
get in trouble,
but are we gonna get in trouble right
now.
Hold on.
What are we doing?
It's going to do something.
Why are we getting in trouble?
Well,
we get our shit pulled from youtube all
the time.
If it has content in from someone else's
video.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You can't even play the audio.
So what is the problem with ice cream
and people listening to this audio will
audio.
Well,
but youtube people are not.
So we're,
we're watching this and Donald Trump was
getting upset at allergy.
People are just hearing silence.
Let's kill it then.
This is stupid to do it this way.
And yeah,
it's um,
whenever someone's content gets played,
like anybody who owns this video,
we play their video,
we get pulled off of youtube and then
what do you do?
You have to go to cut it out,
put it back up.
Yeah,
it's a,
I get it.
They want people to.
But we've always tried to tell people to
go to that video.
That's it.
You're sending traffic their way.
Right?
But it's funny.
Go find it.
Go find it in here.
Yeah.
That's funny.
I didn't know Sacha Baron Cohen was
easy.
A practicing Orthodox Jew belief.
So yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
It's interesting because you think of
comics is,
do you know other religious comics?
Because there's an irreverent and
intellectual irreverence.
There are a few.
Um,
Jim Gaffigan's Catholic.
Oh yeah.
That sort of his shtick.
Right?
I don't know if it's a shtick.
I think he's actually a practicing
Catholic.
How much of that is legit?
No,
I mean that's his.
He's sort of identity.
I don't mean it,
it's just.
I just mean like he's the family man.
He definitely is.
Yeah.
What is this?
Is this him?
Sacha Baron Cohen says,
I wouldn't say I'm a religious man.
I'm proud of my Jewish identity and
there are certain things I do and
customs I keep tries to keep kosher and
attend synagogue about twice a year.
He tries to keep kosher,
but he's not saying he's really wouldn't
say he's a religious Jew,
but he tries to keep kosher.
Alright.
Yeah.
It sounds like he's halfway in one foot
in,
one foot out.
I mean,
you gotta think about the movies he
makes.
You can't,
you can only be so religious and made
those movies.
Yeah,
yeah.
I Dunno.
I,
this whole thing about comics thinking
differently.
A Saturday I was at j Dot Johansen's
house.
He does this cajun cooking every
Christmas.
And uh,
I was there and there was a guy,
a Haney Comic Lustiness,
Alan Haney,
Havey Havey Havey,
uh,
who I recognize from mad men and,
you know,
and then since I met him,
I've seen him everywhere.
He's on that,
a man in the high castle and all these
shows.
Anyway,
so we're there and we're talking and
we're talking about this thing.
We're talking about the stan hope by the
way.
I didn't finish that cliffhanger thing,
but if someone wants to listen to
something,
go check those two episodes out.
Do you go to the names of the episode
called the cliff cliff hangers?
Yeah.
Um,
but it's very intense.
It's very intense.
Anyway,
so we're talking about this and I said,
uh,
have you guys seen this movie,
the aristocrats?
Because it's really about how comics
think differently,
you know,
like how nothing is offensive and
they're like,
yeah,
that's a great movie and that really
gets to it and you know,
whatever the conversation continues.
So then I go home and a couple of days
later I'm sitting there and I had a copy
of the aristocrats and I haven't seen
that since it came out and we're going
to watch it.
So I watched the aristocrats.
They're both in the fucking movie and
neither one of them says anything.
Right?
So it's again,
it's this la thing where everything's
the opposite of,
of what I consider normal.
So in la I thought about this a lot
because it was so shocking to me that
they were just like,
oh yeah,
it's a great film and then I want you to
like,
there they are,
right?
How do you not say,
oh,
we're in that movie.
How do you not say that?
It can only be that in la,
like name dropping is so uncool.
That cool becomes what you don't say.
Yeah,
that definitely could be it because
people see famous people all the time in
la,
so it's like if you're like,
oh,
he saw Joe Rogan in the supermarket.
People are like,
yeah,
whatever,
man.
It could also be that some people don't
like talking about their work.
Some people,
some people avoid talking about
especially talking about the work of
standup when there did not talk to a
standup.
Yeah,
that I do that really?
Yeah.
So you would just,
you wouldn't mention that you were in
the movie.
I,
I get away with not mentioning
it.
I might just scared out of their cars.
I will to you.
I was still a small town boy because to
me it's like you're in a movie.
Oh shit man.
Tell her.
I will certainly tell you that I was in
that movie if you brought it up,
but you my friend.
But if I didn't know you in some Weirdo
at a party,
I got to take a chance with that.
Just talking about standup to you.
Oh yeah.
That's good movie.
Hey,
look over there.
Chips and cheese puffs.
My favorite.
Yeah,
I get cornered sometimes.
I mean you've been cornered sometimes by
people that just want to ask questions
at you,
like they're interviewing you.
So what's going on with like,
like right now I get a million people
that want to corner me and asked me UFC
questions because UFC just sold for some
astronomical for billion dollar,
whatever it is figure.
Right.
And uh,
so everybody wants to talk to me.
What's it like with the new owners?
What's the EU?
It was like,
oh,
gotta go gotta go.
You become like a,
someone that you're,
you're instead of having a conversation
with people like you're interviewing you
and.
Yeah.
And it's one on one.
It's not coming out on TV or something.
Not even that.
It's like,
I don't,
you know,
I don't necessarily want to talk about
my work detail in issues.
Like what's it like working with my new
bosses who gives a shit?
No.
Do you compartmentalize a lot?
I mean,
is there the UFC part of your life and
there's the standup part of your life
and it has to be the UFC because I don't
swear.
I very,
very rarely like say shit or is that
hard?
No,
no.
It's all about her heart.
I just,
uh,
I don't think it's necessary.
They don't like what I'm doing.
I mean to keep [inaudible] you're used
to talking on the podcast.
Is it?
I don't mean.
Does it bother you?
Didn't think you meant that even
difficult?
No,
it's not difficult because it is a
different,
totally different mindset because I'm
never trying to be funny.
Like,
do you remember when like Dennis Miller
used to host Monday night football?
Yeah,
he did it for a little bit because he
was trying to be funny.
He was cracking jokes intersect and I
remember remembering that.
Yeah.
But I didn't even watch it,
but I remember people were like really
pissed at Dennis Miller and I thought
about it and I was like,
well,
I don't do that and I'm not gonna do
that.
And it's like he,
you know,
Dennis is a joke writer.
He's,
he's got,
he's a joke teller,
I've,
I have bits,
you know,
it's kind of a different kind of comedy
in the first place,
but then on top of that it's like that
thing that's going on to me doesn't
require much of me.
What it requires is me to explain
things.
That's it.
So it doesn't require personality or
flay or senses of humor or a unique
point of view other than unless I
recognize something like a pattern
that's happening at a fight that allows
the people at home to enjoy it more.
And it allows the person who's fighting
the two people that are fighting it,
it represents them in an honorable way.
So that's my goal.
That's all I'm trying to do when I'm
there.
I'm just trying to do my best to give
justice to what I'm seeing and to do a
great job with that.
I don't even,
I'm not into UFC.
I've started watching it since I've been
hanging out with you,
you know,
and I've gotten to know some of the
personalities and I've watched the whole
Ronda rousey thing and the,
you know,
this guy,
Irish guy,
conor mcgregor.
You fuck.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's pretty compelling and I think you
do a very good job of that.
Your ego isn't in play at all.
No,
it can't be just reporting.
Yeah,
I try as much as possible to stay
outside of it.
I mean I'm,
I'm thinking because I want to.
I mean I'm constantly trying to stay on
the ball,
but uh,
at my best I'm just doing it,
you know,
it's like I have to be just tuned in,
well rested,
well fed,
hyped up,
ready to go.
It's because it's a six hour thing,
so I sit down for six hours and
oftentimes it's a,
it's always at least 10 fights.
It's usually 11 or 12.
You do all?
Yup.
All of all of them bring you in for the
last few?
No,
actually like doing it that way because
what happens is I get warmed up so I do
like the first one because like
sometimes fighting so crazy.
You have to go,
oh yeah,
okay.
There's a fight going on,
you know,
like you're sitting in.
I mean even though I've done it,
I've called at least a thousand fights,
probably closer to 2005.
I don't know how many actual fights have
been in front of while doing comedy or
commentary rather,
but it's at least a thousand.
Let's say it's probably like 1500 or
something,
but even though that's the case to this
day,
when one starts,
I go,
okay,
this is the fight,
this is what's going on by the fifth
fight of the night.
I'm totally in the groove and I'm just
laser focused,
concentrated on the action,
trying to pick the right words,
trying to describe it in the right way
and trying to give that,
give that perspective to someone at home
that might not be seeing something that
I might be saying.
Well,
especially all the.
The wrestling grappling techniques,
that's a big part of it.
That's a big part of it.
People are used to seeing boxing and
they dealt with an upper cut is or a
book or whatever,
but yeah,
when they get on the ground,
I have no idea what's going on.
And you're talking about the arm bar or
this and that?
Yeah,
that's the most difficult.
Are you below the stage or.
Yeah,
below you see what's going on.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Well sometimes I don't see like if the
referee stands in front of me and then I
have to look at monitoring.
So I have two monitors in front of me
and give me two completely different
angles.
You get splattered by swabbing blood,
blood splatter on maybe before.
Yeah.
I've got into my mouth before one guy
was talking to me and his nose was
broken and every time he's talking at
sprayed and around my lips.
And you're on live television.
Yeah.
Be like,
cut.
Give me a fucking.
Oh No.
You mean he was talking man.
Blood was coming out of his mouth.
Jesus.
Yeah,
I've gotten sprayed.
It's,
that's a easy part.
You know,
their job is,
was difficult.
Like that's someone's blood like that,
the guy getting hit and they're all
tested HIV,
you know,
not everything,
everything,
everything.
And uh,
you know,
guys have been stopped from fighting
because of certain things that have come
up in those tests.
Uh,
diseases and all kinds of shades.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
Hepatitis,
for sure.
Some organizations have,
you know,
pulled guys off cards because they found
the way you should infectious blood to
blood.
That's a bad thing to be.
Getting.
Staph infections are a real big deal
too.
Sometimes people will get staff from the
fight or they're fighting and you find
out the guy had like a sore staff.
One wasn't alerting anybody to it.
That happens.
A biotic resistant now.
Yep.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Staff of scary stuff and it's one of
those things that sort of rarely gets
discussed,
but I'm super important to keep healthy
skin flora.
I tell people this is one of the most
important aspects of it.
Don't use antibacterial soap.
Don't do it.
You're going to ruin your skin.
Flora your fucking agent orange in your
whole skin,
like don't do it.
People think they're going to be
healthier that way.
I'm just gonna use antibacterial that
way.
I want to get into diseases.
You'll get like crazy warts on your
hands and shit like you gotta be real
careful with that stuff.
Yeah.
You don't want to kill that flora.
The Flora.
This is something I researched for this
book that this section is a big problem
because you don't get the vaginal bath,
have a skin flora and also intestinal.
Dave actually rubbed vaginal like
whatever that jazz is on baby post birth
that have given us area and sections
just to sort of that on them because if
you don't it gets colonized by whatever
is floating around in the air and you
don't want what's floating in the air
and the hospital.
Fuck.
Yeah,
no.
it is a crazy thing.
You know that there's a process and we
don't.
We don't.
We think there was some details of that
process.
We can.
We can skirt around that one.
We don't have to blow the pussy out.
No,
no,
no.
We're just going to go through the roof.
We're going to pop up a sunroof on that
bitch and just it off on Monday.
So this stitch them up.
Everything's going to be fine.
She looks great in the vagina.
It retains its 100 percent of the last
test.
We have to acknowledge where a couple of
guys here,
we're never going to have our taints
slit.
Oh,
I get it.
I get it to get it 100 percent.
It's tough,
but I have a friend and his wife like
specifically with saying a baby is not
blowing my pussy out.
Not going to happen.
Yeah,
she,
she's going through the roof.
No matter what.
I fucking get it.
It's a circle.
It's such a primitive way to give birth.
You know the weirdest one is a Hyena.
The hyena that gives birth out of that
fake Dick.
He a big glitzy,
massive clip.
What's a foe?
Penis.
I mean,
it literally looks like a giant Dick and
they're bigger.
That's what's fucked up about them.
They have a baby out of that thing too,
and they ride the mail and try to fuck
them with that fake Dick.
Weird animal.
Maddening is that.
We're so lucky we don't have been here
since I saw you.
What'd you do over there?
Yeah,
so I was in Mexico first,
then there was in Thailand for six
weeks,
and then I was in southern Africa.
I did a 10 day safari.
Botswana.
Yeah.
Was that A.
I wouldn't do the same thing again.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
it was cool.
It was just wild dogs.
Safaris who do this sort of like a low
budget,
get in the van and sleep in tents at
night kind of thing.
And I picked this like massive thousand,
1500 mile,
whatever,
like see all of southern Africa,
which was dumb because you're just
sitting in a van most of the time.
What kind of shots did you have to get?
I didn't get any shots for that.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
there's no yellow fever there.
There's some malaria,
but I've been in lots of places with
malaria and I just avoid mosquitoes.
How do you do that?
You don't,
uh,
you have,
make sure you have a good net on your
bed.
Uh,
you wear long sleeve light colored
clothing,
light colored like white or something
like that because there really are
attracted to darker colors.
Well,
I think it's because you don't see them,
you know,
if you're,
if you have a white sleeve,
you'll see them landing and flying
around.
Oh,
I see.
You're just constantly on the alert for
little disease carrying monsters.
He,
uh,
and also,
you know,
allocational,
he used some of the DDT shit on my
ankles and my neck and stuff.
Um,
but the other thing is you eat a lot of
raw garlic.
Oh,
I heard,
I've heard that.
That's real.
Well,
I mean that's,
I've been doing it for years when I was
on the road backpack and in places,
tropical places.
I was eating raw garlic every day,
which is really good for your
intestines,
your intestinal flora and all that.
But your skin smells like garlic.
You start sweating it out right away.
Oh,
I smell like garlic all the time.
People Complain,
Oh,
I love the smell.
I like it too,
but it's not good on your breath.
Right?
Agreed.
Well,
what what you do is you chop it up,
put it,
throw it in your mouth and drink it down
with water.
You don't chew it.
I chew chewing.
It's what gives you the breadth because
it gets in your teeth.
So if you take it like pills,
you'll get the garlic belch when you get
the garlic skin,
but you don't get the garlic breath.
I would feel like come
cheating because,
uh,
I'm kind of a glutton for those
uncomfortable moments when you know
you're doing something good like a
chomping down the garlic and you feel
those juices hit your tongue and you're
like,
whoa.
You feel out,
your nose starts opening up.
I mix it with some fresh ginger.
I just throw it down,
man.
Yeah,
I mean anytime there's any feeling at
all of stomach disease disease where if
I feel bad,
I don't feel like I'm a little rundown.
I just choked down a bunch of cloves of
garlic the other day I did it and it hit
me so hard.
I had to take a knee.
I was like,
aw.
Like as it was going down,
I was like,
Whoa,
man.
Could have stood up.
I wanted to sit down for dramatic
purposes like wow,
take a knee or praising the Lord.
My goodness.
Garlic,
what are you doing to my insides?
I had a horrendous stomach virus right
around new years.
I went through my New Year's Eve show,
convinced I was going to shit myself.
I was like,
there's gonna be a point in this show
where I'm just going to have to shit
myself.
And I thought about it all day before
the show.
I didn't eat anything,
anything all day.
Like from the moment I woke up to the
moment I went to bed.
I mean that was having broken fire
hydrant experiences in the toilet.
Liquid.
Yeah.
We were just like,
where is all this coming from?
You know,
like I,
I couldn't believe it.
As I was saying,
wait a minute,
it was below anatomy.
Something inside of me was terrible.
Like whatever it was was terrible.
I had these farts that were they,
they smelled like fermented fruit in
death,
like death mixed with this fermented
sulfur,
like,
like the most rotten meat you could ever
cut.
Like if you opened up like a,
a fridgerator and the power had gone off
while you were on vacation and came back
and there was some hamburger meat that
was rotten.
It smelled like that and like,
like sulfur and like a sweet,
like a vinegary,
almost like a fermented sort of a smell
to.
It was getting belches were you getting
sold?
It was all going on in some of my
stomach because I wasn't eating much and
it was something that went around
through my whole house.
My,
my littlest daughter got.
I mean I didn't know what she was going
through,
but she was just constantly complaining
about her stomach being really awful for
like a whole week we were skiing in
Aspen and that's when it kicked in and
when I got back I was like,
oh no,
like this is bad.
Have you.
Have you ever had an event on stage now?
Like a wet fart or something or like,
oh no I haven't,
but interestingly enough,
there's a new law that just got.
Well,
it might be proposed.
A new rule got proposed for the unified
rules of mixed martial arts where if you
shit yourself,
they stopped the fight,
which has happened before because of
shit themselves,
like during the middle of a fight,
just like loss of sphincter control.
Yeah man.
Sometimes you got to go like sometimes
it's diarrhea,
sometimes kick you in the fucking gut
and just blast it out.
The back,
there was a guy named Michael
[inaudible] who was a very good fighter
and he was fighting biennials Douche,
I believe.
Yes.
That's what the fight was.
And Benito diary.
It was a because I remember is a big
victory for him because he choked
biennials Dario out,
which was a giant because Dario,
she's like super respected Jujitsu,
black belt and Michael Chester as he got
into the octagon,
looked over and he goes,
dude,
I might shit my pants because I might
shit my pants.
Right,
right.
While the fights going on,
I'm like,
seriously?
I was like,
took my headphones off.
Like,
seriously?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm going to shit my pants.
And so like,
okay.
I know I sound like I'm holding this in
the back of my head.
I'm like,
I definitely shouldn't bring it up
unless it becomes an issue because I
don't want the public to dwell on that.
I want them to enjoy this great fight.
And then he got through without shitting
himself and then,
uh,
you know,
I asked him after like off Mike,
I'm like,
did you almost treat yourself?
It's like,
dude,
he goes,
I came out here.
I was convinced I was going to shit
myself.
I used to get like before I would go on
a TV show or do a big public speaking
thing where they're going to be a lot of
people there.
I would like five,
10 minutes before I was supposed to go
on stage.
I'd
be like,
I need to take a dump.
Like I need to do it right now.
I've taken a few dumps here.
Sorry about that.
I'm more relaxed now.
It's what it's for,
but I think there's a,
it's like a,
you know,
fight or flight thing.
I think animals get that too.
It's like,
oh,
this is,
I gotta get my shit together.
Literally get it out of me,
so I'm like,
yeah,
you know there was.
Well it's also your body does not want
to waste any resources dealing with that
because it feels like there's like some
catastrophe about to take price.
There's a video of these two bears,
these giant bears and it was in that
movie grizzly man,
they're crazy dude,
that song movie,
but these two bears are fighting and
while they're fighting they start
shitting because their bodies just like,
look,
whatever this says,
get it out,
get it out.
We're going to war here.
We're not practicing.
Yeah,
no,
no thought whatsoever.
And no resources drawn away from the
muscles to process the food because have
you ever done that?
Like eating a big meal and try to work
out.
I never tried to work out,
but if you did,
you got nothing.
No energy,
no energy.
It's fascinating because it's like,
like it's almost like if you were a pie
chart,
you could see there's a segment of that
chart that is now missing.
You can kind of do it.
You can kind of work out,
but you definitely can't run a marathon
or anything crazy.
You can't.
I mean,
if you do,
you'll be hurting all the fucking Wim
Hoff.
Man,
you know,
you've been on your show a bunch of
times.
I hung out with him for like a week and
the Pyrenees and went up to his place in
Holland and like sort of became friends.
I mean,
that's an example of what I'm talking
about.
I want to know these people,
you know,
like when I reached out to them,
they were like,
yeah,
we'll set up a thing.
You can do a skype.
And I was like,
fuck that.
I don't want to do a skype.
I want to meet this dude,
you know,
like,
tell me,
give me a day.
I'll fly to Holland.
I was in Spain at the time,
so it wasn't a big flight.
But anyway,
I was talking to him about it and it's
like he's running all these marathons in
the fucking desert with no water and in
the Arctic and you know.
Yeah.
But the dude doesn't work out.
No,
he runs marathons.
He doesn't work out.
He doesn't run because I hate running.
Yeah.
I'm like,
well,
how do you run a marathon if you don't
train?
He's like,
oh,
it's just the mind.
Yeah.
I don't know what he's talking about.
I ran a five k and I was ready to die,
run up the fucking driveway.
I about her brother and I don't run and
I ran a five k and I was like,
wow,
this is actually difficult.
I'm like,
I'm in great shape.
this,
I'm going to be able to do this.
I work out all the time.
I'm like,
I'm just going to go on this run is
going to be just a thing I do because
we're not used to using those muscles in
that way.
Or was it was was his cardiopulmonary
waffle covered with peanut butter and
then covered with maple syrup.
I gave myself an excuse.
I'm like,
I'm going to run this crazy race car
book,
but my body's just not used to eating
that nonsense,
so I think it had shut down production
of a lot of key ingredients.
There was definitely that feeling like
when I was running,
I could feel like offices from them
waffle coming
up my throat.
I can taste it,
kick it in the peanut butter and syrup
together.
So much sugar.
But it's all just,
you know,
your feet,
your feet aren't used to running on.
It was on concrete.
The whole thing is weird in the shocks
on your knees and your ankles.
You ever read,
born to run?
No.
No,
but I do know the premise of it.
Chris and Doug Dogo.
It's about the way shoes running shoes
are developed and yeah,
and how our bodies are designed to run
on the balls of her feet and he goes
down in the lives with the Tarahumara
Indians in Mexico and the bank,
they'll Kobe where I was in 1988,
so I was back there with those Indians
and they run into like really thin shoes
or barefoot barefoot or they make these
sandals out of the tire,
you know,
and it's just strapped on their foot.
It's just a thing.
And they run forever.
Yeah.
Well,
that's how the body's meant and I mean
we're,
we're meant to use the foot as this
amazing shock absorber,
you know,
you land on the ball,
the frame it was him.
That's what the calf muscles for.
Yeah.
And also the arch and there are all
these bones.
Yeah.
Crazy short.
It's like the birth thing,
you know,
thing yesterday.
The sock is same thing.
I mean it's supposed to be replacing
that barefoot feeling,
I suppose.
It's a really expensive sock.
It's like 80 bucks.
Just a sock,
but kind of a.
it's made,
it shows at the end of the video shows
what it's made of.
It's got some sort of spray polymer
that's like 15 times stronger than
steel.
Whoa.
So you can like do rock climbing,
tightrope walking or running outside and
it's just as a guess.
It feels like silk.
It's it,
it feels just like a sock.
Holy Shit.
I'm pretty interested in it.
I don't know how legit it is,
but just get it pretty new.
I work out barefoot most of the time.
I work out barefoot when I do
kickboxing,
workout,
barefoot.
If I do Jujitsu,
workout barefoot,
if I lift weights,
I do almost everything barefoot.
Occasionally I'll do like an elliptical
machine or something like that with
shoes on,
but I feel like when you are barefoot,
like I do yoga barefoot,
obviously.
I feel like when you're barefoot you get
to feel your toes are like digging into
the ground.
The rolling.
I just,
I feel like it makes a big difference in
a lot of the nervous system terminates
in the sole of the feet.
So there's,
in Chinese medicine there's a lot of um,
attention paid.
Reflexology is about how,
you know,
I don't know how real it is,
but it is real that the,
a lot of the nervous system terminates
at the soles of the feet.
That's why foot massage feels so good.
And so the theory is with this barefoot
shit is that by having that experience
you're describing where your toes are
digging in and you're feeling your
weight being shifting in different parts
of your foot.
Having that part of your body alive,
inactive is really good for your overall
psychological health and nervous health.
Does that makes sense?
Does make sense?
Yeah.
It just feels good to do and there's
like,
you feel good for a reason,
right?
You know the word evolve too.
To have them feel good because it's good
for us.
Brings us back to beaten off or fucking
one of those
dog things.
I drinking off a dog with A.
I wonder if we should call that company
and ask questions and they say like,
what kind of dog do you have?
Oh,
I don't have a dog.
Yeah,
this nefarious intentions.
I just like watch dogs.
Fuck robots.
It's just for dogs that wonder by my
friend Joe when I was growing up,
Joe Spagnolo and he had a.
He had a dog that was just like really
ornery little dog and his dog had a
stuffed animal that it would fuck and it
would just bite this stuffed animal and
fuck the shit out of it.
And you'd come over his house.
Joe's bags.
You'd go over his house and his dog
would be fucking the shit out of this
stuffed animal.
And you're like,
whoa.
How'd you'd clean it?
I don't know.
I mean,
you couldn't even go near that thing.
That dog was like,
he would get ferocious if you tried to
get near his stuffed animal.
There's a little tiny ass dog too.
I don't remember what he was.
That's like your friend with the
restraining order,
man.
Love is love,
you know,
there's no way around it to do.
But that dog was obsessed.
That was his world.
His world is like biting the stuffed
animal and just plug into have.
Hey,
somebody asked me to raise an issue with
you.
Uh,
apparently you've,
you're under the impression that
everyone died at 30 and prehistory.
Is that true?
Uh,
I,
I joke around about that all the time
that lifespans were incredibly low.
A long time ago.
Lived to be like 30,
you know,
it's a hyperbole for the most part.
Okay,
good.
I know people did leave love live
longer,
but the age that people died,
the average age was much lower than it
is today just because lots of babies
died.
So it's,
yeah,
it's a mathematical average.
But species by design by has evolved to
live into our sixties and seventies and
hunter gatherers who get through the
first few years where there's a lot of
risk.
So it's a huge thing also.
It's all rounded out math thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So I was under the impression that
people just got diet of violence and a
lot of diseases by the time they were in
their thirties.
No.
Most of the diseases that we suffer from
are the result of agriculture.
So you look at all the major killers of,
of humans.
Swine flew from pigs or chicken pox from
chickens.
Obviously Avian Flus come domesticated.
And Jamie would,
he posted up there?
Human lifespan.
Nearly constant for 2000 years.
Oh.
So like ultimate lights fan.
But when I was talking about most of
these diseases and violence,
yeah.
The,
the violence thing is overrepresented if
you,
unless you live in Mongolia.
If you read the.
Yes,
what is it?
Seventy five.
And I don't know if that looks free.
History is this?
No.
Good.
Okay.
Uh,
life expectancy for men in 19.
Oh,
seven was 45 years.
Forty five years by 1957,
it rose to 66,
2007 to reach 75.
Unlike the most recent increase in life
expectancy,
which is attributed
largely to a decline in half of the
leading causes of death,
including heart disease,
homicide and influenza.
The increase in life expectancy between
19 Oh,
seven and 2007 with largely due to the
decreasing,
decreasing infant mortality rate,
which is like nine point nine,
nine percent.
That's interesting.
So what that is like is like the wage
gap,
the gender wage gap issue,
right?
Where a lot of people say they love to
quote that thing that say that men make
so much more money than women that women
make eighty cents to the dollar,
but they're doing different jobs.
Right?
So like you think about it,
you go,
wow,
there's an injustice going on.
And then you realize like,
well maybe there is some sexism,
but this is not what they're talking
about when they're saying this.
They're talking about different jobs.
The men are at higher risk,
they die more often on the job.
Men like when they almost exclusively
populated the community of minors and
lumber jacks and shit like that,
where people get hit by trees and women
take time off when they have kids and
they also work less hours.
They're less crazy.
Some men will fucking work themselves to
death.
Were very few women will.
Yeah.
Take it to that list.
Certainly are plenty of examples of men
and women doing exactly the same job and
women are getting paid less.
I'm sure it must have been,
but it's not statistically
significantly.
It's not what you're talking.
They attribute that from the.
When women get less,
they think that one thing to be
considered when you look at that is that
women might not be as aggressive when
they're negotiating a starting salary
and that men may be more confident and
cock shore of their worth more cocky
with how they,
uh,
who knows though.
I don't,
but it's one of those things.
So I was under the impression that
people did die.
Yeah.
Well,
most people are under that impression.
I've,
I've had,
I've spoken,
given talks at medical schools and stuff
and all these doctors think that
everyone died at 35 to 35 year old
results and they're like,
and it works its way into medicine where
they're like,
okay,
look,
the reason you have chronic back pain is
that the human body was not evolved to
live beyond 35,
and so of course you have wear and tear
and things like that's totally false.
The human bodies evolved to live into
the seventies,
so it's a statistical thing.
It's like if Bill Gates moves into your
neighborhood,
suddenly everyone's average annual
salary is million,
hundreds of millions of dollars,
right?
So if you count all these infants who
died in prehistory,
many of whom by the way died from
infanticide.
Like twins normally are not allowed to
survive.
The,
the weaker one is left in the woods to
die.
Yeah.
Any sort of deform and mal formality,
we just leave them in the woods by
themselves.
What a cruel way to handle it.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's dark man.
They would leave him to wolves.
That's fucked up,
man.
Leave your baby in a basket.
And run away.
Ooh,
yeah.
There's a lot of,
a lot of infanticide,
but you know,
in our world,
a lot of it,
huh?
Yeah.
Well,
just because of the times were harder
than.
And it was more accepted that you were
going to have to do some terrible things
that you didn't want to do.
Well,
it's just,
you know,
if a kid's
born physically fucked up in some way,
you know,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna have the resources and
that kid's not going to,
that person's not going to grow up to
contribute to the group.
And so generally,
and also there's a different sense of
life and death,
you know,
I think we're death is much more a daily
presence.
It's not that big a deal.
So we're all going to die there.
I was reading about a tribe in the
Amazon.
Uh,
I can't remember the name of the tribe,
but when someone gets too old to keep up
with the group,
someone has chosen randomly,
like they have a lottery or pick the
shortest straw or whatever it is.
And their job is to come up behind this
old person and hit him in the back of
the head with a hatchet.
Oh boy.
Right.
And no one wants to do it.
It really sucks,
but everyone agrees it has to be done.
And it's the least cruel option that
they've come up
real careful to do to keep signing up
for that job.
Exactly.
Got It.
Last time.
So Papa Joe,
you've killed nine old ladies this way.
This bitches gone over.
Okay.
We'll just let her stop.
Ooh,
that's weird.
That's a weird gig.
So anyway.
No human being has ever been old at the
age of four.
Look at this
heartbreaking pictures of parents
leaving their children in China's
notorious baby hatches.
So yeah.
What is that?
Well,
that's,
that's probably girls.
The moment of despair.
As parents cling to their children for
one last time before abandoning them in
China's so called baby hatches,
the father kisses his child,
her face hidden in a blanket.
The mother holds her hooded baby has
their shadows are cast upon the last
door they will pass through together.
Another collapses to the ground,
reaching out to touch her son for the
last time.
What in the fuck?
Oh my God,
the baby is.
She says in quotes,
my baby cannot take care of itself when
it grows up.
One woman cries explaining that her
infant has down syndrome.
I just want my baby to survive.
She tells the information times news
based in.
I don't know how to say that.
Guang huge owl.
She had an accompanying female friendly.
Both in tears.
Fuck man.
Well,
this has been happening forever.
I mean,
we have safe baby drop
Bob's here.
Every hospital has a sign that it's a
safe baby.
Drop off.
Take that off the screen or
and in medieval Europe it was so common
that they had these little boxes that
rotated and so you could leave your baby
and just spin the box.
They didn't have to look at it.
No one would ever see,
you know.
See who was dropping it off.
It was anonymous.
Oh my God.
Very common.
They called a foundling hospitals and
over 90 percent of the babies left there
died bad
boy in Germany.
They had with.
What are they called?
Angel makers?
This,
and this is through the beginning of the
20th century up to World War II.
It was a nanny that you hired with the
understanding that your baby was going
to die,
so it was like a babysitter who's going
to kill your baby?
Oh my God.
Yeah,
so you would hire this nanny because
your kid had down syndrome or some sort
of a disease or something like that,
or it was born out of wedlock,
you know,
whatever.
The nanny would kill the baby.
Oh my God.
They called them angel makers.
The idea that infanticide was
historically significant.
It's significant in the death of the
population that that was so common.
Well,
I mean today we have abortion and I
don't want to get into,
you know,
heavy shit,
but like now if a baby's inconvenient or
there's a disease that's detected or
whatever,
you know,
cut it off at the past,
you cut it off at the pass.
In those days there wasn't.
So it was sort of postnatal abortion
essentially.
I feel like abortion is one of those
subjects were
ideally upon breaching the subject.
There's a tension in the room.
I've just felt it.
I apologize for it.
You know,
you're right.
There's no way.
Because the thing is both sides are.
Right,
right.
That's the problem.
You're 100 percent,
right?
Yeah.
That's 100 percent the problem.
And there are a lot of issues like that.
Yeah.
It's one of those things where people
screaming at you and get crazy and
they'll pick a side and it's death and
it's this and it's that and it's,
it's a woman's choice to choose.
And it's,
you're both right.
You're both right.
Like I got in an argument once with the
comedian about it and he,
it was about Richard Dawkins was talking
about a,
um,
it was on twitter that an embryo,
human embryo is like,
it's almost no different than a pig
embryo.
Like he was making this about at six
weeks of life or whatever.
It would be a very,
very,
very early age.
I guess not even,
that wouldn't even be an embryo.
Right.
What would it be?
Still an embryo,
an embryo.
Then right,
okay,
so an embryo is the earliest stages and
he was comparing it to a pig and I was
like,
well,
you know how crazy that is a ridiculous
thing to say because it's not going to
be a pig,
but if you leave it alone it's going to
be a person so you know it's going to
grow up to be a person.
Like.
It's like saying that it's no different
than a pig.
It's totally disingenuous.
So I mean this comedian,
we were arguing and he started calling
me,
you a right winger.
He's like saying that I was,
that I was writing.
I'm like,
I am not right wing,
but you are definitely killing a person
that's about to be born.
I mean,
that's what you're doing.
You're cutting it off.
What you cut off at three cells or three
months.
It's the same thing.
It really is.
I mean,
be.
It's not.
It becomes.
It becomes much more like a baby.
It looks more like a baby.
It's more,
it's more intensive and a procedure,
but once the process is started,
you've decided at various stage of the
way that it becomes okay.
You know,
like late term abortions are frowned
upon by almost everybody.
Right?
When you get into the fucking the last
couple of weeks of a baby's life,
you can't really.
Or before it gets birth,
nobody.
Very few people are going to agree that
you could just suck out the baby with a
vacuum when it's nine months old.
You know?
That's,
that's a little intense,
right?
Almost everybody agrees that's a little
intense.
So that means that we all have some sort
of a reasonable cutoff.
Anybody who believes in abortion,
we have some sort of a reasonable cutoff
will were accepted when it's a bundle of
cells,
when it's.
When it looks like a fish,
like when is it?
Okay,
when's it okay.
And that's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying you should or shouldn't
be able to do it and it's definitely not
my choice.
I don't have a body that makes baby.
And do you think it starts at conception
or jerking off?
Killing millions of.
Because jerking off doesn't ever make
that connection,
there's not,
it's not a viable.
So it is conception process that
started.
I mean I don't necessarily think life
starts at conception.
I mean I literally have.
I mean if someone can prove like if you
had a Turkey tester that pops up when
you're pregnant,
like the moment,
Oh shit,
we got one and you can just push that
sucker down.
That egg would shoot out.
That fertilized egg would shoot out of
your pussy and then that would be a
wrap.
I got no problem with that.
Right?
I don't know a problem with any of it.
I mean I do.
I think intellectually I don't.
I wouldn't say I have a problem with it
because again,
I submit that I don't have a vagina,
I don't have ovaries,
I don't have a womb.
I'm not making babies.
I have an opinion and that's it.
There's no way I should be able to say
yes or no when I see it as this weird
sort of a situation where we've figured
out a way to terminate life inside the
body where we can't see it yet.
It hasn't come out and said,
hi,
Hi Daddy.
It hasn't done that yet,
so we could hit the brakes.
Okay.
I don't want to.
I don't want to do it.
Whew.
We figured it out.
I don't think that there's.
I don't necessarily think it's wrong or
right,
but it is a thing.
You know,
it's a thing and people require that you
speak of this thing in the way they
speak of this thing and if you don't,
they are fucking ready to Duke.
They're ready to duke it out with you.
I,
I.
because the differentiation is the pro
choice.
People are saying it's not a life and
the other people are saying you're
killing a living thing.
A person and I'm,
I'm in there where it's like,
no,
you are killing something,
but it's not a person now yet.
So I agree with both.
Right.
You know,
but fundamentally I agree with what you
just said,
which is it's really none of my fucking
business.
It's not my body and no woman can tell
me whether you get a vasectomy or not or
the prostate exam or whatever the fuck
it is.
They just passed a law in Arkansas or
somewhere that husbands need to be
informed before woman can have an
abortion and a husband can stop it even
if she's been raped.
That's medieval.
That's ownership person.
Yeah.
A husband or a wife.
Being able to tell the other one what
they can or can't do with a medical
procedure.
That's illegal.
That becomes like an owner.
That definitely becomes an ownership
issue.
Like if your wife told you you couldn't
get a vasectomy,
I will not allow it,
but what?
I will not allow you to eat meat either.
I will not allow you to have ice cream
fat.
Fuck.
No.
Like all of a sudden she decides what
you're going to eat out.
It will not allow you to keep that
haircut.
Ryan.
That way all
the time.
Oh,
I would never let my husband buy blah
blah.
Like what?
Your husband's a pussy.
Yeah.
Well,
and your wife is under threat or in,
you know,
under ownership.
If she allows the same sort of situation
like guy makes her do things.
Yeah.
I've known people that are.
Their husbands have made them get
plastic surgery.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
talk him into it.
You know,
I want you to do this for me.
Get the big tits.
Yeah,
get the lips,
lips,
the lips to do something by your nose.
I don't like your nose.
Bothered me.
You'd be prettier,
baby.
I'll show you off.
Weird,
weird.
You fix your notes.
And then there are those people who like
who like fatties,
you know?
Then the,
they feed the other person.
It's part of their eroticism to feed you
as much as possible so you get as fat
because I love you and getting,
you know,
it's not cool.
Very strange.
People are fucking weird man.
You know,
I don't think hunter gatherers are
kinky.
No,
no.
This is the thing.
I think kink is a response to a fucked
up environment.
So I think yeah,
it's this weird pressure.
It's conflict between the impulse and
what's allowed.
So it comes out in this weird,
distorted way.
I think that makes total sense.
So yeah,
hunter gatherers,
there's not,
as far as I know,
there's no evidence of Kink,
tarred to get latex.
Let's face it,
the jungle,
although that's where it comes from
originally.
If you've ever met Wade Davis,
by the way.
No,
you should meet that guy who is
fascinating.
I just had him on my podcast.
He's an ethnobotanist.
She live around here.
He lives in Vancouver.
Um,
but he's an author.
He,
I'm sure he comes to la regularly,
but,
uh,
he's the guy actually we were talking
about five Meo dmt.
He was,
he and Andrew Weil isolated that for the
first time,
uh,
as white people.
Anyway,
he studied at Harvard.
Then he went to the Amazon for a long
time.
He worked,
lived with a lot of tribes.
They're very interested in
hallucinogens.
He's written a bunch of books.
His first book was about Voodoo,
um,
something about the horsemen of the
apocalypse or something like that.
He wrote a book called one river.
He's written seven or eight books.
He's a national geographic explorer in
residence.
He's the super bad ass dude.
Damn.
I told one of his stories on your
podcast a long time ago about this
Eskimo Dude,
old guy in the family said,
Grandpa,
you know,
we get to take away the keys to the snow
machine because you can't see so well,
and he's like,
fuck you guys.
In that night he went out,
it was winter in the Arctic somewhere.
He took a shit and he fashioned a blade
from his shit out of the snow and well
he killed the dogs and he made a harness
out of the dog's skin and a little sled
out of the dog's ribs.
And then he like tied in three or four
other dogs and then he fucking took a
took off across Tundra.
Anyway,
that's a way David's story.
He's like,
he.
So he made a knife out of his own chef.
He froze his night.
He,
he forms the blade and then he took
some.
He freezes and then he takes them spit
and he rubs it along the edge and
apparently that's what gives it the
razor sharpness.
Yeah.
And then he fucking kills his dog with a
shit knife.
That's right.
I remember that.
There's another story,
Davis,
how I bought Zombie poison in America
inside the eclectic quarter of award
winning writer Wade Davis,
former national geographic explorer in
residence,
ethno,
botanists and park ranger is a super
cool guy.
Christ what?
A life that guys lived.
Yeah.
He's A.
Again,
that's the guy like I want to fucking
meet these galleries.
Yeah.
So he's cool.
He's up in Vancouver.
Well,
listen man.
Unfortunately I got a book.
Yeah,
we can do this alone to time though,
man.
You're a.
you're in the back in the states.
I am.
I got nothing to sell.
I had no.
Doesn't matter,
man.
Lazy Hippie lifestyle that will promote
your podcast.
Tangentially speaking.
So hilarious.
Awesome podcast.
And you do it fairly recently?
Fairly often.
Every week.
Okay,
cool.
That's awesome.
And let's do this more often.
Dude.
Year round.
I'm here and it's that Chris Ryan.
Now.
It used to be Chris Ryan,
phd on twitter,
but Duncan trussell fucking ruined him.
And Brendan Walsh,
they stole my phd.
Those fuckers,
they put phd next to their name.
Now Phd doesn't mean anything anymore,
so that Chris Ryan.
Thanks brother was awesome,
man.
Yeah,
you too.
See you guys.
Bye.